nous décrypterons comme chaque soir du
lundi au jeudi l'essentiel de
l'information avec nos invités toujours
tenus à bonne distance et nos reporters
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mardi des dizaines de milliers de
soignants dont dix huit mille à paris
dans les rues après les promesses du
président mais kron objectif obtenir des
actes concrets en plein de ségur de la
santé à paris le cortège parti du
ministère de la santé a été émaillée
d'échauffourées au niveau de l'esplanade
des invalides
les forces de l'ordre ont fait usage de
gaz lacrymogène ont honte 24
interpellations à dijon laurent en une s
promet une réponse ferme et un
renforcement du dispositif après les
quatre nuits consécutives de violences
et d'expédition punitive menée par des
membres de la communauté tchétchène dans
le quartier des grésillés elle gendarmes
mobiles crs bac hommes du raid sont
entrés en action hier soir une réaction
jugée trop tardive selon l'opposition de
droite
[Musique]
le couperet est tombé pékin referme
toutes les écoles de la ville appelle
ses habitants à ne pas quitter cette
ville en cause une résurgence de k2
qu'ovide la mairie alerte d'une
situation d' extrêmement grave alors que
plus d'une centaine de personnes ont été
contaminées depuis la semaine dernière
dans la capitale chinoise
les mégalopoles de 21 millions
d'habitants a porté sa capacité
quotidienne de dépistage à plus de 90
mille personnes un symbole de la détente
sur la péninsule réduit à néant la corée
du nord a détruit le bureau liaison avec
le sud qui avait été ouvert en septembre
une mesure prise par pure mion avec des
tracks critiquant kim jong-un ont été
acheminés sur son territoire
washington exhorté pyongyang à éviter de
nouveaux actes contre productif
[Musique]
mobilisation nationale des soignants
dans toute la france les appelait tous
les français qui les ont applaudis
ces trois derniers mois les rejoindre
dans la rue en première ligne pendant la
crise sanitaire et après les promesses
des manuels macron le personnel de santé
veut des actes alors que se joue en ce
moment le ségur de la santé pour une
refonte du système hospitalier
à paris où l'on dénombre 18 mille
manifestants des échauffourées ont
éclaté en marge du cortège
plusieurs centaines de manifestants
habillés en noir ont mis le feu à du
mobilier urbain et jeté des projectiles
les forces de l'ordre ont répondu par
des guides des tirs de gaz lacrymogène
on compte 24 interpellations dans la
capitale et on retrouve tout de suite
sur place notre reporter nadège
abderrazak qui a suivi donc ces
manifestations bonsoir nadège quel bilan
peut-on tirer de cette nouvelle journée
de mobilisation des soignants m'a écouté
ils étaient des dizaines de milliers
d'infirmiers de médecins aides soignants
à participer à cette grande mobilisation
aujourd'hui pour demander plus de moyens
publics pour plus de moyens pour
l'hôpital et les revendications elles
sont à simple des augmentations
significatives de salaires des créations
d'emplois et l'arrêt des fermetures à
des services des établissements et des
lits je vous propose justement d'écouter
certains manifestants on est
systématiquement contre la violence mais
le pouvoir a décidé qu'il jouerait sur
la violence sur la violence sur la
violence pour dire regardez c'est infect
gens ces soignants à qui on disait bravo
bravo bravo et bat aujourd'hui on va
l'aider crac et bientôt comme des
dangereux personnage
ça m'attriste profondément parce que
depuis le début tout se passer
correctement
c'était une manifestation bon enfant on
sait faire entendre et en arriver à
attaquer les forces de l'ordre ne suis
pas sûr que nous ça nous serve à quelque
chose
nous les forces de l'ordre on les voit
quand on passe à côté en laurent les
salue on a du respect pour ça fait quand
même assez mal après ce qui s'est passé
en france avec d'épidémie qu'ovide de
voir que des le premier rassemblement
bon ben voilà c'est le même traitement
inquiets qui est donnée donc un jour on
cogne sur les pompiers aujourd'hui c'est
les soignants gbp émis trois mois en
danger dans un service qu'ovide par
manque de matériel d'accord ça a été
cautionnée par l'état tout le monde
pouvait commander des masses qu'ils ont
juste interdit de le faire je prend pas
plus de risques d'être infectés de
retour de 30 patients qu'aux vide à
l'heure actuelle une manifestation qui
était autorisée par la préfecture de
police de paris qui a démarré dans le
calme depuis le ministère de la santé
qui avaient pour objectif de se
poursuivre jusqu'à l'assemblée nationale
le cortège arrivait ici à esplanade à
des des invalides et bien des tensions
ont éclaté cette manifestation pacifique
s'est transmis aux enfants
c'est transformé en violents
affrontements entre forces de l'ordre et
manifestants des manifestants et bien
qu'ils ont été infiltrés par des
centaines d'individus cagoulés habillés
de noir qui est bien sont venus pour en
découdre avec les forces de l'ordre
plusieurs dizaines de personnes ont été
blessées chez les manifestants mais
aussi auprès des forces de l'ordre
trente deux personnes ont été
interpellées à l'issue de ces
affrontements
du mobilier urbain a été dégradé des
voitures incendiées et même à des
véhicules
des voitures ont été retournées ici
voilà ce que l'on pouvait retenir de
cette grande manifestation aujourd'hui
du personnel hospitalier à paris merci
nadège abderrazak et pour en parler nous
sommes avec barbara tout est infirmière
à l'hôpital lariboisière à paris
coordinatrice du collectif inter urgence
bonsoir barabara goût et oui merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors le mot d'ordre c'était voilà
appelé tous ces français qui vous ont
applaudi pendant la crise à venir à vos
côtés elles vont soutenir à ce que vous
les avez retrouvé ses france est à vos
côtés cet après midi
oui j'étais là et beaucoup de
d'autres collectifs beaucoup de
personnes des usagers de la santé
deux personnes de tout venant les gens
qui fréquentent les hôpitaux en fait
chaque citoyen un jour affaire à
l'hôpital et
il était là après
là les complications
sur la suite on fait que certains ont dû
partir et on sait tout à fait
compréhensible
ça n'a pas été facile la fin de la
manifestation oui effectivement 250 à
300 400 parmi lesquels des ultras jaune
en pré cortège
selon certains témoins se sont mis en
action apparemment dès l'arrivée aux
invalides votre réaction est ce que vous
avez le sentiment ce soir qu'on vous a
d'une certaine façon voler votre
manifestation est peut-être voilà
masquer vos revendications
il ya deux manières de considérer ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui une manière très
corporatives on pourrait dire oui on est
déçu mon
on attendait depuis très longtemps de
pouvoir manifester avec tous les
évènements des mois passés on en avait
besoin on avait besoin de se retrouver
tous ensemble et de dire qu'on existait
et que on se battait pour tout le monde
pour les patients quand ils consultent
on veut de la dignité à l'hôpital on
veut les moyens qui sont déjà dans les
textes en fait donc c'est ça nous a fait
mal au coeur que ça se déroule de cette
manière mais dans le même temps
ça rejoint toutes les revendications
sociales la détresse certains sont ultra
son ultra radicaliser et ça peut
s'entendre parce que ça fait des mois
aussi qu'ils sont en revendications et
qui demandent que toutes ces
problématiques sociales soit mise
sur la place publique et fasse l'objet
d'un débat et
ils ont trouvé comme opportunité les
soignants on peut on peut pas faire
grand chose en tout cas il y était aussi
là pour nous soutenir à la base
échauffourées c'est vrai qu'on a
toujours le risque qu'on ne parle pas du
fond est ce que vous le craignez
aujourd'hui que finalement les chaînes
de télé ce soir parle davantage de ces
échauffourées moins des revendications
allons précis sur rt qu'on parle très
très régulièrement tous les jolis de vos
revendications on a le plaisir de
d'invités voilà très régulièrement des
infirmiers mais enfin voilà il ya ce
risque peut tout de même le bas le
risque est réel mais effectivement je
pense que au delà de des médias depuis
un an et demi nous sommes sur le terrain
et avec les événements passés
suite à la pandémie du coc vide chacun a
pris conscience des difficultés que
vivent l hôpital et les a fait un peu
sienne parce que même si on n'a pas été
contaminé ou pas en difficulté et par
nécessité de soins urgents
on s'est dit que oui effectivement en
termes de cinquième puissance mondiale
il y avait des des faiblesses à
l'hôpital public et les gens se sont
appropriés nos revendications en se
disant si un jour je dois avoir besoin
de l'hôpital est-ce que c'est dans cette
conditionna ça va se passer et la
réalité à ses jours a pour tous nos
concitoyens et je pense pas qu on
effacer nos revendications après
effectivement médiatiquement parlant bas
des voitures retournées et du gaz
lacrymogène c'est c'est une belle image
alors l'un porte sur l'image
le gouvernement vous entendant plein
ségur de la santé aujourd'hui quelles
sont vos principales inquiétudes on sait
que vous avez des revendications
majeures le salaire les lits pour vous
il y aura quand même
voilà des points qui seront respectés
par le gouvernement vous l'espérez en
tout cas
l'espérance on espère toujours beaucoup
on va passer
les espoirs sur le ségur son
sont limitées on a l'impression que le
jeu il est déjà fait c'est pas parce qu
réunis et les acteurs autour d'une table
que le débat ait réellement ouvert
aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
si chacun chaque français s'approprient
les problématiques de l'hôpital et se
les fait siennes on pourra aboutir 1
vrai mouvement de fond pour aboutir à
terme à des modifications et la volonté
de voir la santé comme une priorité pour
l'ensemble de la population française
merci barbara coût est infirmière à
l'hôpital lariboisière à paris
coordinatrice du collectif inter urgence
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france et on en vient à présent ces
violences inédites à dijon pour la
quatrième soirée consécutive dans le
quartier sensible des grésillés des
hommes cagoulés pour la plupart ont semé
le trouble tout a commencé avec
l'agression d'un adolescent d'origine
tchétchène par plusieurs personnes
d'origine maghrébine selon les membres
de la communauté tchétchène sans vie et
militaires ont été déployés une
quarantaine de crs et même leur aide
une enquête judiciaire est ouverte le
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur promet la fermeté
j'ai évidemment décidé de renforcer le
dispositif que nous avons mis en place
sur le terrain puisque ce soir il y aura
à dijon deux unités de force mobiles qui
seront présentes sur le terrain ça veut
dire prêt de près de 150 fonctionnaires
aux militaires de la gendarmerie plus
les effectifs locaux
je veux passer un message très clair aux
voyous que nous avons vu exhibé des
armes aux individus qui sont venus comme
être ici des violences à dijon notre
réponse sera extrêmement fermé ce
dispositif sera maintenu
et puis le deuxième point il va se jouer
évidemment avec le procureur de la
république puisque des investigations
judiciaires sont lancés sur l'effet sur
les violences qui ont été commises six
adjoints et je ne doute pas une seule
seconde que ces investigations qui sont
menées par la police judiciaire de dijon
qui sont menées par la sûreté
départementale de la sécurité publique
de lions mais aussi par les services de
police nationale
je ne doute pas que ces investigations
permettront de confondre un certain
nombre d'auteurs et qui seront forcément
donc poursuivis et sévèrement punis à la
hauteur
actes graves qui se sont qui ont été
comme ici mais je veux vraiment dire que
la réponse que nous allons apporter
elle sera forcément la réponse de la
fermeté parce que l'ordre républicain
c'est d'abord et avant tout cela et
c'est dans ce contexte que les policiers
manifestent leur ras-le-bol la nuit
notamment à paris en cause des
déclarations récentes du ministre de
l'intérieur sur les sanctions pour les
fonctionnaires en cas de soupçons avérés
de racisme une polémique dont se sont
emparés certains leaders politiques
c'est le cas notamment de jean luc
mélenchon qui souhaitent je cite une
police aussi désarmé possible pour
qu'elle inspire le respect alors qu'à
droite on en demande davantage de
fermeté alors faut-il désarmer la police
française fallait-il notamment
intervenir plus tôt et plus fort après
les inédites opération de représailles
de tchétchènes à dijon c'est l'objet de
notre face à face ce soit et pour en
débattre à nous sommes en direct avec
jean lain la capelle député européen
délégué national du rassemblement
national bonsoir jean lain la capelle
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france à vos côtés vikash dhorasoo
ancien footballeur proche de la france
insoumise bonsoir vikash dhorasoo merci
d'être avec nous alors une police aussi
désarmé que possible pour qu'elle
inspire le respect je reprends les mots
de jean luc mélenchon c'est une bonne
idée il cache dhorasoo les policiers qui
inspire d'ailleurs plus de crainte que
de respect oui la desservir déjà moi
j'irai plus loin il parlera en
s'inspirant de ce qui se passe aux etats
unis
il ya des endroits où on notamment
minneapolis angola la des finances et à
ordiphones en en anglais voilà alors de
lui donner moins de moyens financiers et
prendre cet argent et l'utiliser
évidemment pour régler les problèmes
sociaux juste l'exemple d'aujourd'hui si
on avait donné plus de moyens à
l'hôpital hôpital public
les infirmiers les infirmières les
personnels soignants ne serait pas dans
la rue on n'aurait pas eu besoin de la
police en face
qui vient de réprimer quand même les
gens qu'on applaudit c est qu on ne
compte qu'on présentait comme novilleros
il ya quelques semaines
évidemment moi je veux pas que cette
police on veut de la justice et c'est ce
qu'on n'a pas en ce moment
jan marek appelle aussi petit monsieur
mélenchon qui demandait à ce que on
désarme les policiers et puis ce matin
il demandé à ce pour des armes les les
les gangs et les bandes de tchétchènes
notamment donc il veut qu'elle envoie
les forces de police en petites
socquettes avec avec les mains dans le
dos bon c c'est une hérésie bien nés
avant que de formuler cela je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on à l'illustration d'une
faillite de l'état en quelque sorte et
c'est pas d'ailleurs la première fois
que on assiste à des scènes comme celle
de dijon parce que ça arrive en ce
moment également à nice et à ivato est
arrivé à marseille vous avez des bandes
structuré armée qui font la loi en toute
impunité il a fallu quand même trois
jours pour que le ministre de la défense
donne des consignes mises de l'intérieur
parents donnent des consignes à hauteur
de l'ordre pour intervenir afin de
neutraliser la situation à dijon 3 jours
où donc ces bandes armées ont pu faire
leur loi régler leur compte tout seul en
toute impunité
c'est la triste conséquence d'une
immigration incontrôlée et d'un laxisme
politique qui marque 30 ont clairement
on essayait d'acheter la paix sociale
dans ces quartiers où on est a dit
finalement tous les habitants et on a
investi des milliards et des milliards
justement dans les rues de la ville
on voit bien que ça ne marche à rien ça
ne mène à rien et que finalement ça
aboutit à quelque chose de très
dangereux qui le séparatisme publica et
vikash dhorasoo il ya plusieurs idées
dans ce que dirait jean lain la capelle
d'une part on aurait peut-être
intervenue trop tard il ya aussi cette
notion d' immigration incontrôlée quelle
est votre réaction
mais évidemment je suis pas vraiment
d'accord alors moelleux les guerres de
gangs dijon
et cetera voilà on pourrait en parler
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est cette
police coq est aujourd'hui remise en
cause parce qu'on l'a
allez allez violente elle elle frappe
elle tue parfois c'est une étude c'est
un racisme systémique qui se retrouvent
dans la police parce qu'évidemment on a
décidé par exemple que ces populations
dans nos quartiers populaires les noirs
les arabes étaient des personnes
dangereuses donc on va les chasser
alors que ce ne sont pas des personnes
jose les gens dans les quartiers
populaires sont français les petits
jeunes là sont français ce qu'ils se
font attaquer régulièrement et contrôler
juste parce que les jeunes couleur de
peau qui ne convient pas à longueur de
journée d'ailleurs le défenseur de
droits on a des droits on a parlé d' a
souligné c'est jusqu'à 20 fois plus de
contrôles quand on est un jeune noir un
jeune arabe par la police donc le climat
de peur que ressens tu sais ces gens là
il est pas lié à autre chose que
l'immigration est derrière autre chose
que des migrations
il est lié à un contexte de racisme
systémiques liés à l'état et liées à la
police donc moi c'est ce qu'il faut
changer est évidemment l'immigration n'a
rien à voir dans tout ça puisque il
suffirait d'accueillir bien les gens qui
arrivent en france il faudrait faire on
est un pays riche on est capable
d'accueillir correctement les gens qui
viennent en france les mettre dans des
conditions correctes et évidemment la
guerre des gangs
si certainement autre chose mais je
crois pas que la police puisse se régler
la guerre des gangs
en arrivant elle même avec des armes est
encore plus armé que la fois d'avant
garde jusqu'à cette notion d'immigration
par abandon à la capelle 1 ça fait écho
du côté de la punissent de l'intérieur
annonce un examen systématique de
l'expulsion des étrangers impliqués
justement dans ces événements à dijon
c'est une réponse qui vous semblent
satisfaisantes du côté du rassemblement
national
oui vous savez moi je me méfie toujours
de céder le gouvernement mails nacro
nous a habitué le a exprimé beaucoup de
mots et des maux contradictoire avec
bien sûr ceux qui l'appliquent et sera
donc élue
le ministère il ya une bonne part
d'exane donc moi je crois que dans les
faits il faut être beaucoup plus serré
dans ces moments là il faut restaurer
l'état de droit on
question aujourd'hui qui est grave dans
certains quartiers et il faut bien avant
que la loi de la république soit
respectée donc il faut moi je crois
renforcer justement les moyens à la
police il faut soutenir la police au
contraire de ce qu'a fait aucun scanner
qui a failli la semaine dernière qui a
cédé aux revendications de la rue d'une
poignée d'ailleurs de manifestants
soutenus ou manipulés soit par l'extrême
gauche soit par la famille traoré donc
quand on peut pas dire que l est l
héroïne familles d'enfants de choeur
tout de même mais je crois que non il
faut redonner confiance à la police
aujourd'hui leur donner des moyens et
ils vivent ils exercent leurs missions
dans des conditions difficiles
je n'apprends pas du tout raciste si un
acte raciste il faut bien sûr le traité
et le condamner mais je la crois
adossant que dans sa grande majorité
extrêmement sincère loyal aux règles et
aux valeurs de la république
et puis il faut aussi que la justice
fasse son boulot c'est à dire que des
délinquants ou des gens qui ont pu
participer à ces à ces scènes comme
celle de dijon depuis le 4 jours il faut
les interpeller il faut les juger
il faut les condamner sévèrement de
manière à ce que ce soit dissuasif
vikash dhorasoo vous avez fait pas mal
de manif
vous même vous parliez tout à l'heure de
ces échauffourées qui se sont produits
cet après midi dans les manifestations
de soignants vous dites voilà la police
a réprimé ces soignants qui se sont fait
applaudir pendant la crise est-ce que
tout de même vous accordez une forme de
crédit à ce que dit jean lain la capen
sur la manipulation est ce que ces
personnes qui viennent parfois cagoulés
vêtus de noirs dans les manifestations
et qui brouillent parce que ça ce sont
les soignants qu'il dit c'est pas moi
qui le dit qui brouillent leurs messages
et leurs revendications est ce que voilà
vous pensé justement qui a parfois aussi
une forme de manipulation
alors juste pour pour répondre à
monsieur n'étions pas quelques personnes
à la place de république la place de
république était bien pu remplir le
stade de france le soir dans un match de
finale de coupe du monde le stade de
france accueille 80 mille personnes suis
pas si vous vous rendez compte le nombre
de personnes qu'il y avait là des jeunes
noirs blancs arabes asiatiques moi je
suis d'origine indienne réunis pour la
même chose en dénonçant les mêmes choses
la violence de la police et violences
policières et le racisme systémique qui
vise une certaine catégorie de la
population donc évidemment c'est pas
quelque chose d'anodin
autant de monde qui se réunissent c'est
pas anodin aussi que nous tous étions
d'accord à scander les mêmes choses et
ce jour là
évidemment il se passe rien la
manifestation est super le préfet
l'allemand l'autorisent puis après
l'interdît et puis en plus on est menacé
on est empêché de circuler par cette
police qui en même temps le jour-même
autorise une banderole néo nazis sur pas
par un groupe néonazi sur les murs et
qui appelait les personnes parties alors
que nous on a été gazés alors qu'on
était complètement pacifique à notre
exemple pour contredire évidemment ce
que ce que vous dites c'est que aux
états unis il ya pas si longtemps les
policiers ont dit ah si c'est ça nous on
bosse plus une partie de la des
policiers ont décidé d'eux de poser les
menottes comme vous les policiers
récents l'ont fait et bizarrement il n'y
a pas eu plus de violence plus de crimes
plus et vient même baissé et puis je
pense souvent à alors il ay foot qui
étaient là la maire de chicago une des
villes les plus violentes des états unis
qui est une femme noire et lesbiennes
qui a décidé de régler tous les
problèmes sociaux par des mesures
sociales sans jamais faire appel à la
police
elle a baissé et les violences dans la
ville à baisser l'insécurité le
sentiment d'insécurité parce
qu'évidemment ça n'existe pas parce que
juste moi je ne me sens pas en
insécurité dans ma ville par contre je
me sens pas en confiance quand je croise
un policier
et ça c'est lié à mon histoire d'un
enfant ici l'immigration qui vient d'un
quartier populaire
j'en ai la capelle sur justement le
désarmement de de cette police est
effectivement à minneapolis on a démonté
la police cette idée pourrait faire son
chemin ce que ça vous inspire quoi
donc je crois ce n'est pas le problème
mais je voudrais quand même revenir sur
la butte française qui est une et
indivisible et l'invisible ça veut dire
zéro que weeds à risques comme ceux
dhorasoo dit qu' il y avait à cette
manifestation des blancs des noirs
les gens de toutes les couleurs moi cela
m'est totalement égal pour moi il ya des
français gens qui ne sont pas français
mais quelle que soit la couleur de peau
l'origine la religion des gens quelles
que soient leurs racines
ça m'est totalement égal j'estime que
nous on est français par d'autres choses
deviennent amants et notamment par le
respect des valeurs à notre république
française vous faites allusion de ce
dhorasoo à la manifestation il ya
quelques jours elle m'a mise en fait
votre affection parce que ces
manifestations illégales
donc en termes de respect de lois et de
modèles et d'exemple je souris un petit
peu d'autre part pour parler d'une
manifestation qui déclare n qui
expliquait un message d'antiracisme très
bien moi j'ai entendu du sale juif et du
sale blanc pendant cette manifestation
et enfin ça c'est quand même terminé par
des dégradations matérielles et dont on
sait que ce sont les français avec
rimbaud qui régleront cela donc qu'ils
apprécieront donc vous pouvez pas d'un
côté demander plus de justice et de
l'autre côté ne pas la respecter
je crois qu'il ya une contradiction dans
ce que vous dites mais ceci ne me
surprend pas de la france est soumise
dans laquelle vous vous portez qu'à
toulon
votre réponse des cages dhorasoo et puis
le mot de la france si elle sait que la
journée autre ibère comme vous dites
elle sert aussi à payer la police alors
donc on a le droit d'avoir un mot sur
sur cette police qui nous pour nous
frapper et board tu me lis donc c'est
aussi nous qui la payons juste lorsqu'il
ya eu les moments un peu qu'ils ont
cafouillé
c'est des gens du comité à damas qui ont
protégé qui ont empêchés et qui ensuite
se sont fait taper par la police ait eu
qui en paie si les casseurs
ils se sont mis devant ils ont empêché à
ça traoré a condamné les propos
antisémite d'une seule personne
après je voudrais juste vous parlez de
mâcon tout à l'heure macron n'a pas
soutenu la manifestation et la suite
plus la police dans son intervention il
a soutenu la police qui est violente et
n'a pas parlé des violences policières
donc il a soutenu donc il a évidemment
je me sens je pense un peu parlé aussi à
l'extrême droite qui est inquiet de ne
pas nous moi les gens qui étions à la
manifestation nous sommes français
nous ne voulons pas de ces pratiques
nouveau pas faire bande à part
nous voulons juste l'égalité nous
voulons être traités comme les autres
quand il parle du privé est blanc on
pense que être blanc dans l'espace
public
c'est un avantage de ne pas par exemple
ne pas se faire contrôler trouver un
appartement est bas nous voulons la même
chose ne pas être contrôlé quand on est
un homme de couleur
et puis là la démocratie le libres et
égaux en droits il faut que ce soit vrai
aussi c'est pas vrai vous voulez prendre
la place d'un homme noir cabu dans un
quartier populaire monsieur vous allez
voir si on est libres et égaux en droit
en france
allez-y faites le prenez la place faite
le et pourquoi aujourd'hui même s'ils
montraient une en pis quand vous êtes
interpellé mais rapidement parce qu'on
arrive à la fin donc on vient de voir
l'illustration sélectif d'ailleurs dû
descendre à sa liste le ce dhorasoo qui
parle de privilèges blanc mais monsieur
leurs assauts avait même dit d'ailleurs
qu'il était d'origine indienne
je crois que son papa était mauricien il
est arrivé en france il ya quelques
années un oav
ils étaient accueillis parfaitement par
la musique française il a pu travailler
là chantier naval du havre monsieur
dhorasoo vous vous même perdu profiter
des institutions profiter des centres
d'entraînement profiter des services
publics et vous êtes devenu un grand
footballeur international tout ceci vous
lever la rue française dont la gauche
française allait pas raciste elle est
une indivisible
encore faut-il les mais encore faut-il
épouse est encore utile la respecte et
de partager dans la soupe et respecter
ses lois
voilà mon mot de la fin merci à tous les
deux genres à la capelle vikash dhorasoo
d'avoir accepté ce débat en direct sur
rt france resté avec mon dans quelques
instants nous parlerons de pékin en
plein regain épidémie calamel
alerte d'une situation extrêmement grave
de nouvelles mesures restrictives ont
été prises puis direction ensuite la
corée du nord qui a détruit le bureau de
liaison inter coréens instauré à la
suite du rapprochement d'avril 2010 8
entre les deux corées attend ainsi la
fin de la phase de détente
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
à
l afrique et compte 1 1 % de cas dans le
monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez nous devons considérer que
les chiffres sont sous-estimés mais nous
ne sommes pas encore au niveau où se
trouve par exemple les rock ou les états
unis quelle stratégie
vous avez déployés dans le sud kivu pour
limiter la propagation du virus on a
proposé à ceux qui les confinements
puisse être sélectif est concerné
seulement des personnes âgées à haut
risque de complication pour sensibiliser
la population
ça l'est beaucoup plus facilement
puisque on venait de sortir d'une d'une
épidémie d'ebola qui exige également la
distanciation social lavage des mains et
si on aura affaire à deux épidémies
aussi dangereuse qui est beau la et
coronavirus ça pourrait être très très
difficile
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre 20h30 heure de
paris en direct sur rt france pékin
referme toutes les écoles et appelle ses
habitants en ne pas quitter la ville
la crainte d'une seconde vague resurgi
en chine où tout a commencé plus d'une
centaine de personnes ont été
contaminées depuis la semaine dernière
dans la capitale le maire a lancé une
campagne de dépistage massive la
capacité de dépistage vient d'être
d'ailleurs porté à près de 90 mille
tests par jour ce regain de contagion
est partie de l'immense marché de gros
de sin famille dans le sud de la
capitale pour contenir l'épidémie la
municipalité ordonné le confinement de
près de 30 zone résidentielle ainsi que
des sites culturels et sportifs
si aucun décès lié au qu'ovide 19 n'a
encore été détecté l'om et suit la
situation de près beijing pékin est une
grande ville est une ville très
dynamique et connecté donc il ya
toujours une préoccupation et je pense
que vous pouvez voir ce niveau de
préoccupation dans la réponse des
autorités chinoises donc nous suivons
cela de très près
les cursus et pour en parler nous sommes
avec catherine hill épidémiologiste
bonsoir catherine hill merci d'être en
direct avec mon sur rt france pékin qui
referme dans toutes les écoles de la
ville qui appelle ses habitants à ne pas
quitter la métropole quelle est votre
réaction est ce qu on assiste clairement
à une résurgence à une deuxième vague
vous c'est un peu prématuré de
s'exprimer ainsi
je pense que c'est prématuré c'est
effectivement l'arrêt la une arrive et
nouvelles du virus dans la apk parce
qu'il y avait pas eu de cas depuis
longtemps et tout d'un coup il ya eu on
en a fait à peu près 30 diagnostic
chaque jour dans les trois derniers
jours quelque chose comme ça à peu près
mais les chinois font ça très
sérieusement et il teste massivement la
population et j'ai comparé le nombre de
cas rapportés à la population pékin qui
est de 22 millions et 34 30 cas par jour
pour 22 millions de personnes c'est
moins que le nombre de cas qu'on a en
france chaque jour dans les trois
derniers jours
bon là on a à peu près trois ou quatre
fois plus donc c'est pas en france on a
des confiné tout le monde
on teste continuer à tester très très
peu de gens puisque on fait moins de la
moitié des 700 mille tests qui sont
disponibles chaque semaine donc les
chinois prennent la chose beaucoup plus
sérieusement que nous optimise attributs
d'une certaine manière ce n'est pas plus
qu'un cluster en france
non mais je ne parle pas de ces papas de
chaque cluster en france je parle du
nombre de cas en france
au total chaque jour pour l'ensemble de
la population de 65 millions en france
métropolitaine
il ya plus de cas pour les 65 millions
de français de france métabolise n ya
plus de cas chaque jour qu'il n'y en a à
pékin depuis trois jours où on voit une
résurgence du virus donc il était arrivé
à un état beaucoup de de contamination
bien plus faible que nous et ils sont
revenus à un niveau qui est plus bien
plus faible que celui que nous avons
aujourd'hui alors
ce qui peut frapper catherine il sait
que un nouveau un marché alimentaire est
soupçonné on a quand même le sentiment
depuis la france que l'histoire se
répète
vous nous dites ici voilà vous êtes la
deuxième invitée nous dire voilà les
autorités chinoises on peut compter sur
l aide c'est sous contrôle mais voilà
toujours c'est problème de marché que
peut-on faire qu'on peut t'on suggéré
aux chinois si on peut leur suggérer
quelque chose c'est pas à nous lorsque
j'arrivais c'est à nous deux c'est à eux
de nous expliquer comment ils ont fait
pour éviter par exemple que le virus
n'arrive à pékin auparavant ils ont
vraiment très très bien manoeuvré les
premiers première épidémie a été très
très largement confinée à roubaix à la
province de omrane et il ya eu très peu
de cas à pékin il ya eu neuf morts en
tout à pékin
donc jusqu'ici se sont très bien
débrouillés donc on va leur faire
confiance ils savent très bien se
débrouiller et je constate qu'en france
on continue à ne pas tester massivement
la population à oignies à lui de nouveau
quelques cas et ils ont testé 11
millions de personnes en dix jours et
nous on ne fait pas assez de test il
faut trouver les gens qui sont porteurs
du virus et qui en contamine d'autres et
il y en a en france tout le temps
puisqu'il ya des nouveaux foyers tout le
temps aujourd'hui clairement est ce qu
un scénario similaire est possible en
france vous dites on continue à ne pas
tester
est ce qu on pourrait craindre
précisément justement plus que des
petits foyers localisés mais
une deuxième vague en raison de ce
manque de tester vous dites souvent sur
ce plateau en raison peut-être d'un
manque de rigueur sur le port de masques
notamment
mais s'il ya 300 nouveaux cas chaque
jour en france et on nous raconte
quelques quelques foyers mais on nous
raconte pas où sont tous les cas et on
nous raconte pas les cas dans les ehpad
on nous raconte pas les cas
asymptomatiques qu'ils restent chez eux
et qu'ils sont pas diagnostiqués donc je
pense que le problème en france
sous-estimer est sous-diagnostiquée
aujourd'hui qu'elle peut être justement
l'attitude des autorités vous dites
c'est sous-estimer sous-diagnostiquée ça
veut dire qu'on nous cacherait
volontiers volontairement plutôt des
choses ou tout simplement voilà on est
passé à autre chose après épidémie
peut-être un peu trop vite
oui on épand c'est à dire qu'on en sait
plus penché sur la première économique
sur le problème sanitaire et on n'a pas
pris la mesure du problème qui est que
la moitié des contaminations viennent de
gens qui sont pas symptomatique donc ils
ne savent pas contaminants donc si on ne
cherche pas les porteurs asymptomatiques
est la seule façon de les trouver c'est
de faire des tests systématiquement dans
la population qui n'a pas de symptômes
alors l'épidémie continue c'est ce qu'on
voit c'est vrai que mr bruit c'est vrai
que olivier verrons nous avait dit voilà
on a des tests sont 1000 mais on va pas
les utiliser parce qu'aujourd'hui
l'épidémie est en recul il a dit ça il
ya quelques jours alors on précise quand
même que jérôme salomon entre temps nous
a quand même précisé que l'épidémie
était loin d'être terminée c'est vrai
qu'il ya beaucoup de confusion de la
part parfois des autorités on a du mal à
voir clair il faut regarder combien il
ya de nouveaux cas chaque jour c'est sur
le site du gouvernement tout le monde
peut aller regarder et il y en a encore
et un peu partout donc le virus continue
à circuler
le fait qu'il y ait tous les jours une
baisse des chiffres en réanimation une
baisse de chiffre pour la ddc fort
heureusement et d'admissions dans les
hôpitaux est ce que tout de même
ça veut dire que c'est bon signe parce
que la courbe ne cesse de descendre ça
s'abaisse pas vraiment c'est quasi
constant et puis tous les mardis on
rajoute les décès dans les ehpad donc on
va voir demain enfin en fait mercredi
les données du mardi sorte et on voit
toujours un petit rebond
donc ça descend par vraiment c'est
stable ses attraits l'apidémie continue
à très très bas bruit très très
doucement un virus n'a pas disparu merci
catherine hill épidémiologiste d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
les tensions en corée à présent alors
que la corée du nord avait fermé tous
les canaux de communication avec son
voisin du sud elle va désormais plus
loin
ce matin-là détruit un bureau de liaison
d'une ville située près de la frontière
réaction elle contre les transfuges
nord-coréens qui depuis le sud renvoie
au nord des tracts de propagande anti
kim jong-un lieux met en garde pyongyang
contre de nouveaux actes de provocation
alors que des deux côtés de la frontière
nord et sud coréens se jette la pierre
les nord coréens ne sont pas crédibles
pour le moment peu importe notre
générosité à leur égard ça finit ainsi
c'est pourquoi la corée du sud devrait
également les aborder comme ils le font
actuellement
je pense qu'il n'est pas bien d'être
unilatéralement gentil sans répondre à
leur agressivité
les gens doivent tenir leurs promesses
j'ai vu que le président moon a fait sa
promesse avec la déclaration commune
nord-sud du 15 juin
de telles promesses aurait dû être tenus
par les deux parties plutôt que par une
seule
les autorités sud coréennes sont
désormais contraintes de payer le prix
de leurs crimes et de leur mise en scène
d'un appel au dialogue
nous ne pourrons jamais pardonné à ce
gang ignoble qui a osé tester l'autre
fois et d'autre
détermination à défendre notre chef au
prix de nos vies ouvert en septembre
2018 le bureau de liaison détruits ce
matin représentait le premier instrument
physique de communication ouvert entre
les deux pays depuis cette avancée
majeure les relations entre les deux
corées n'avaient cessé de se détériorer
le point en images
[Musique]
tous
et pour en parler nous sommes avec le
général 2 min traque ancien chef de
mission militaire française
l onu bonsoir générale 5 ans merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france alors plus de bureaux de liaison
le message de la corée du nord est
extrêmement clair ce bureau c'était
avant tout un symbole
oui c'était un symbole il n'existait pas
depuis très très longtemps et ça faisait
partie de l'amélioration des relations
entre la corée du nord et la corée du
sud est donc pour l'instant on s'attaque
aux symboles oui tout à fait alors ça
veut dire quoi c'est un symbole donc ce
n'est pas si grave
simple coup de pression ou peuvent gérer
provocation non je pense qu'il y a deux
manoeuvres dans cette affaire il ya une
manoeuvre qui est la réaction au trac
qui ont été envoyés sur la corée du nord
par des dissidents qui était passé en
corée du sud et donc il faut marquer de
façon très très dur dans les paroles au
moins mais ne pas prendre de mesures
dramatiques
l'armée par ailleurs a indiqué qu'elle
était prête pour la guerre ça c'est le
tout ce qui est visible ce qui est moins
visible c'est que pour une fois c'est la
soeur du leader qui a parlé et non pas
le leader
et donc je pense qu'il ya une montée en
puissance la de la soeur cadette qui est
quelqu'un qui apparemment a appris
beaucoup de place dans le régime
effectivement la sarre qui a des propos
d'ailleurs assez belliqueux pourquoi on
peut se poser la question cette
stratégie de pyongyang qui cherchent
tout de même revenue mais les relations
entre les deux corées qu'elle est
l'arrière pensée s'il y en a une on
baissé de se placer alors sur les deux
plans de marc et qu'elle n'accepte pas
la propagande qui est fait par le sud
vers le nord
ça c'est un premier point qui est
constant dans la république coréenne
populaire coréenne est la deuxième point
c'est que pour être un leader en corée
il faut être très martial très va-t-en
guerre et c'est un peu le langage de la
soeur actuellement
pour marc et qu'elle prend sa place dans
la hiérarchie auprès du leader
alors pourquoi maintenant ces tensions
entre les deux corées quel est le
contexte au global
alors écoutez je il faudrait vraiment
rentrer à l'intérieur du système et ce
qui est un petit peu compliqué vous en
douter mais lors de la crise du corona
virus qui a touché un petit peu la corée
aussi on a beaucoup parlé de maladies
qu'avait le leader et en particulier
qu'il avait été opéré
alors tout de suite après on a montré
des images pour montrer que ça n'était
pas vrai mais on se doute qu'il n'est
pas en très très bonne santé et donc il
ya peut-être une manoeuvre qui consiste
à faire monter en premier plan quelqu'un
qui pourrait lui succéder s'il y avait
un problème
ça veut dire que effectivement la soeur
de kim jong-un pourrait justement être
cette personne qui succéderait oui on le
dit depuis longtemps que c'est quelqu'un
de très influent souvenez-vous les
rencontres elle était présente à côté de
son frère
donc ça c'était un jeu des gestes
importants mais là il apparaît seul donc
ça veut dire qu'elle grimpe encore un
cran dans cette éolienne en chine et
cette capacité de lancer des messages
au nom du pays alors il ya eu des
réactions à ces tensions à washington
qui exhorte pyongyang notamment éviter
de nouveaux actes contre-productif
quel peut être le rôle justement des
états étrangers notamment des états unis
dans cette affaire on précise que les
négociations notamment sur le nucléaire
n'ont pas encore abouti hier
vous faites bien de le préciser parce
qu'à part les shows du président sambi a
pas eu grand chose avec la corée du nord
ceux qui ont vraiment un impact c'est
naturellement la chine et je ne pense
pas que ce que peut dire le pré le
gouvernement américain puisse avoir un
impact sur la corée du nord
est ce que peut dire l'union européenne
qui s'est aussi exprimée en ce sens
qu'il fallait arrêter les provocations
non mais toutes ces déclarations sont
les bienvenus mais je ne suis pas
persuadé que ça ait un impact sur le
gouvernement
si ce n'est que ça montre l'importance
que nous accordons aux réactions de ce
gouvernement dictatorial alors un
précise tout de même un 2003 quand je
m'adresse aux militaires les deux corées
sont toujours techniquement en guerre
depuis plein mixte et oui bien sûr ils
sont techniquement en guerre est
d'ailleurs une des déclarations de
l'armée n'était que l aller fortifier la
ligne de démarcation alors que celle ci
avait été neutralisée depuis quelques
temps donc c'est de revenir à un niveau
de confrontation
doit-on craindre clairement une escalade
ces prochains temps non je crois qu'il
va y avoir des démonstrations quel type
de démonstration un tir de missile
quelque chose comme ça mais je ne pense
pas que ça puisse aller à une
confrontation
le gouvernement du nord n'y a pas
intérêt merci mission militaire
française à l'onu d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france ô
rencontre aujourd'hui à moscou entre le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
et son homologue iranien hormis le
dossier nucléaire sergueï lavrov et
djawad tarifs ont évoqué la situation en
libye et en syrie
le point sur cette entrevue avec notre
correspondant à moscou antoine claireaux
oui avec le déconfinement qui se précise
c'est le retour des déplacements
diplomatiques
ainsi sergueï lavrov a accueilli ce
matin à moscou son homologue iranien
javad tarifs pour parler de la libye de
la syrie mais avant tout des
conséquences encore aujourd'hui du
retrait américain de l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien signé en 2015 le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères a
dénoncé les pressions qu'exercent les
états unis sur les membres européens de
cet accord sur les pays européens qui
ont signé ce texte je vous propose de
l'écouter
après parce que le retrait des états
unis de façon unilatérale
c'était a compris que toutes ces
possibilités qui émanait de l'exécution
honnête de cet accord sont tombés et
vous fiez donc qui était stipulé dans la
résolution 22 30 rd nations unies et les
tentatives des états unis de bloquer
l'exécution il a besoin des clauses de
cet accord le kg et qui lui interdisent
donc travailler avec l'iran et qui
punissent les pays où les entreprises
qu'ils travaillent et qui rompent
l'embargo je considère que c'est
l'emploi de moyens illégaux
ceci n'a aucune perspective d'avenir
cela ne permettra pas une reprise des
activités normales et l ensemble des
obligations dans deux lire entre que d
autres signataires
de l'accord tout ça ça fait partie d'un
ensemble cohérent java tarifs a de son
côté remercié son homologue russe pour
avoir envoyé une lettre secrétaire
général des nations unies qui vient
plaider la position de l'iran sur ce
dossier le ministre iranien regrette en
effet que rien n'est fait au niveau des
nations unies pour tenter de sauver cet
accord
ce respect du droit international et le
principe qu'il y aurait une grillée par
les etats unis se sont retirés de
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien ce
qu'il fait préoccupante pour nous
claironner poster m'appelle à tous à
respecter la transparence y compris dans
le cadre de la loi et quand on voit que
ceux qui ne respectent pas les principes
de leïla et essaie de détruire
l'accord nous croyons qu'ils ne doivent
pas utiliser l'ipad
à cet égard nous sommes à fréha côté ray
avec la russie pour renforcer la
transparence
il a également été question de la syrie
java tarifs revient tout juste d'un
déplacement à ankara et les chefs d'état
de la turquie de la russie et de l'iran
se sont mis d'accord sur la tenue d'un
nouveau sommet dans le cadre du
processus d'astana afin de tenter de
trouver une issue politique au conflit
en syrie un sommet qui devrait se tenir
avant le mois d'août est très
probablement en vidéoconférence train
dans quelques instants rester avec nous
nous reviendrons sur les manifestations
des soignants dans toute la france et
sur l'ouverture de la commission
denquête devant l'assemblée nationale
pour disséquer les défaillances dans la
gestion des crises du coronavirus et
puis nous parlerons de colbert des
militants antiracistes souhaite que la
statue de l'ancien ministre de louis xiv
situé devant le palais bourbon soit
déboulonner dimanche le chef de l'état
lui était clair la république n'effacera
aucun nom aucune trace de son histoire
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
mais on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un en 42 résilience
la catastrophe économique dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté qatar ce trop fine il
ya un tournant mais on re se remet à
vivre mais dans une autre direction
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais une décision après semblable
pour vous ça dépend quelle valeur on
attribue à la mort et à la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie revient
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
moral un débat éthique
[Musique]
il est évident qu'avec le coc vider avec
ce qui s'est passé alors là on va
atteindre plutôt de gens sous employés
ou au chômage qui vont être des liens
dans un horizon relativement court on va
voir effectivement le taux de chômage
exploser en france il ya un grand nombre
de mesures qui sont aujourd'hui déployés
et puis aussi des concertations qui sont
en cours avec les partenaires sociaux
auxquels son salon voulait pas de mesure
c'est pas l'état quitterait les postes
je vous rappel c'est les entreprises et
les gouvernements successifs ont bien
compris que sur le marché du travail
il fallait soutenir la création
d'emplois par les entreprises un
malheureusement on va payer tous
collectivement l'incompétence de nos
dirigeants
[Musique]
l afrique et compte 1 1 % de cas dans le
monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez nous devons considérer que
les chiffres sont sous-estimés mais nous
ne sommes pas encore au niveau où se
trouve par exemple l'europe ou les états
unis
quelle stratégie vous avez déployés dans
le sud kivu pour limiter la propagation
du virus on a proposé à ce qu'est le
confinement plus être sélectif est
concerné seulement des personnes âgées à
haut risque de complication pour
sensibiliser la population ça allait
beaucoup plus facilement puisqu'on
venait de sortir d'une d'une épidémie
d'ebola qui exige également la
distanciation social lavage des mains
qui était si on aura affaire à deux
épidémies aussi dangereuse qui est des
mollahs et corona
ça pourrait être très très difficile
pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça fout les jetons on est dans une
espèce de déni collectif on ne veut pas
croire ce qu'on sait et scientifiques
parlent comme anne de la sixième
extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
et à d'autres experts qui contestent nos
rues si l'ordonnancé personnes non non
c'est pas vrai il ya des crimes à tous
et non ce n'est pas rien à part il ya
des gens qui ne sont pas des chercheurs
qui parlent que la presse met en avant
parce que il faut que du débat mais il
ya plus de débat aujourd'hui
y a plus aucun débat ce changement
climatique et on va vers un brin par une
catastrophe on va vers une vraie
catastrophe et on est incapable d'en
prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas de pessimisme tout
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons de vue est l'ennemi
y'en a pas d'ennemis l'ennemi c'est nous
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort ici on reçoit ce
qu'on ne voit pas ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce que si c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
principe même de notre association c'est
de réduire les inégalités d'accès à la
santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer en soit vous avez proposé deux
posters en falck salle que ça veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
quoi construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
l'histoire est plus compliquée que
certains veulent nous le faire croire
vouloir à la réécrire pour faire oublier
les échecs ne permet pas de comprendre
ce qui s'est vraiment passé
c'est ainsi que dans certains manuels de
cours d'histoire de nos enfants on veut
faire oublier napoléon bonaparte grand
organisateur de l'état moderne pour
profit de robespierre
le père de la terreur j'ai écouté le
président entrant pratiquer le déni en
oubliant carrément l'allier qui a eu le
triste privilège d'avoir le plus grand
nombre de morts dans la deuxième guerre
mondiale mais si j'ai bien compris ils
sont morts pour rien puisque au nom
d'une idéologie on nie leur existence en
oubliant une partie de la game
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la crise du coronavirus s'aggrave en
amérique latine situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
présidant un brésilien g1 max hoarau ni
la gravité de la pandémie il a été élu
c'est par un dictateur il reste encore
populaire et donc évidemment sa façon de
se comporter par rapport au virus a de
l'impact auprès des brésiliens
aujourd'hui le gouvernement travaille
fortement pour s'approprier les
territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon y disparaît nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
certains disent que nous sommes pas une
chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
tous les secteurs de la culture sont
sont touchés la musique le cinéma le
théâtre elle les musées avec trois mois
de nos activités ou les billetteries
sont à l'arrêt l'impact financier est
énorme
ce sera un redémarrage sous conditions 1
avec port du masque obligatoire
distanciation physique gestion des flux
que ce que nous attendons c'est
effectivement la possibilité de rouvrir
sans ces mesures barrières le plus vite
possible
on retrouvera pas le marché que nous
avons quitté en 2021 il faudra
reconstruire le marché se reprendre à
plusieurs mois voire plusieurs années
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission il est
21h heure de paris tout de suite voici
les titres de l'actualité de ce mardi 16
juin des dizaines de milliers de
soignants dont dix-huit mille à paris
dans la rue après les promesses du
président macro objectif obtenir des
actes concrets en plein de ségur de la
santé à paris le cortège a été émaillée
d'échauffourées au niveau de l'esplanade
des invalides
une journée marquée également par
l'ouverture de la commission d' enquête
parlementaire à l'assemblée sur la
gestion du coc vide
premier à être auditionné cet après midi
jérôme salomon qui affirme que la
réponse de terrain était de haut niveau
jean baptiste colbert la ctu du ministre
de louis xiv trône devant l'assemblée
nationale mais sa présence n'est pas au
goût de tout le monde
en marge des manifestations racistes à
travers le monde plusieurs effigie de
personnages au passé sulfureux ont été
déboulonnées par les manifestants
emmanuel macron assure lui que la
république n'effacera aucune trace ni
aucun nom de son histoire
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
les conséquences économiques du commis
19 elles se font ressentir partout dans
le monde de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée les transferts d'argent de
la diaspora mais free ken présente en
europe devrait connaître un recul de
plus de 20% cette année selon la banque
mondiale
un véritable coup dur pour les
populations locales la pomme de la
discorde bruxelles annoncé aujourd'hui
avoir ouvert plusieurs enquêtes contre
apple
la commission européenne soupçonne le
géant américain de pratiques anti
concurrentielles notamment sur le marché
de la musique en ligne du livre audio ou
des services de paiement électronique
la firme de copertino se défend-elle de
tout abus de position dominante
[Musique]
les soignants appelé donc aujourd'hui à
une mobilisation d'ampleur nationale
partout en france des rassemblements se
sont multipliées cet après midi à paris
notamment la manifestation rejointes par
des gilets jaunes a dégénéré des heurts
avec la police ont eu lieu et plus d'une
vingtaine de personnes ont été
interpellées
les précisions ni l'anafé radiant la
mobilisation se voulait symbolique
éprouvés par plus de trois mois d'une
crise sanitaire sans précédent
les soignants appelé ce mardi à défendre
leurs conditions de travail leurs
salaires et obtenir davantage de moyens
pour l'hôpital public
des rassemblements soutenu par les
syndicats on attendre revalorisation des
salaires et la reconnaissance des
qualifications
on attend encore la haye l'ouverture de
lits l'embauché de personnel la
réouverture d'hôpitaux et ne pas
considérer que l'argent qu'on remet à
l'hôpital c'est une dette pour montrer à
ses investissements et donc faut arrêter
de parler de dettes à l'hôpital
on sait qu'on a une politique
défaillante au terme de niveau de
rémunération de carrière les nôtres
camarades sont mobilisés dans ses
négociations pour obtenir justement des
résultats et consent n'arrête pas
remerciements aux applaudissements et
aux paroles mais que cela se traduise
bien concrètement bordeaux lyon
marseille nantes
au total 220 rassemblements étaient
aussi prévus dans tout le pays
a paris alors que la manifestation avait
pourtant commencé dans le calme
des échauffourées ont éclaté dans
l'après midi au moment où le cortège
parti du ministère de la santé arrivé
sur l'esplanade des invalides
le rassemblement a viré à l'affrontement
avec plusieurs manifestants jets de
projectiles véhicules dégradés incendie
de mobilier urbain des violences
auxquelles les forces de l'ordre ont
répliqué avec de nombreux tirs de gaz
lacrymogène
sur ces images également une blouse
blanche violemment percuté par un groupe
de police une situation chaotique qui a
créé la consternation dans les rangs des
soignants ça m'attriste profondément
parce que deux
le début tout se passer correctement
c'était une manifestation bon enfant on
sait se faire entendre et en arriver à
attaquer les forces de l'ordre ne suis
pas sûr que nous ça nous serve à quelque
chose
nous les forces de l'ordre on les voit
quand on passe à côté on les salue on a
du respect pour
voilà est allé leur foncer dedans ou
leur balancer des trucs directement
c'est inacceptable ça fait quand même
assez mal après ce qui s'est passé en
france avec l'épidémie qu'ovide de voir
que des le premier rassemblement bon ben
voilà c'est le même traitement
inquiets qui est donnée donc un jour on
cogne sur les pompiers aujourd'hui c'est
des soignants c'est du grand n'importe
quoi
des incidents très violent qui ne
devrait toutefois pas faire oublier le
combat des soignants alors que le ségur
de la santé doit concrétiser d'ici début
juillet le plan massif d'investissements
et de revalorisation promis par le
président emmanuel macron l'ensemble du
corps médical
combien poursuivre la mobilisation
nombreux tas les rennais également été
dans la rue comme plusieurs autres
villes françaises
plus de 2000 personnes ont manifesté
dans le cadre de cette journée de
mobilisation nationale
et contrairement la capitale tout s'est
déroulé dans le calme
je vous propose d'écouter la porte
parole du personnel soignant présent on
a été soutenu par la population n'a été
soutenue par le gouvernement
beaucoup de discours et là il ya un
retour à la normale trois mois après
nous on attend voilà d'avoir des vraies
mesures qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
qu'ils soient prises en charge pour nous
pas pour le patient pour la santé
publique en fait faut savoir que les
salaires sont quand même gelé depuis dix
ans donc nous on n'a jamais eu
d'augmentation de salaire pour vous
donner un exemple ça fait 12 ans que
chez infirmière je suis payé 1780 euros
net par mois en étant titulaire depuis
plus de dix ans et en travaillant le
week-end
ces médailles on a décidé d'être à 100
mais symboliquement un objet de
revendications puisque évidemment par
rapport aux besoins réels de l'hôpital
elle ne nous servira à rien les choses
qui vont nous servir
c'est plus de lits plus de postes les
recrutements massifs pour faire face à
un besoin des populations
évidemment des salaires françois leroy
contenter tous une nouvelle commission
d' enquête parlementaire aujourd'hui
devant l'assemblée nationale jérôme
salomon a été entendu le premier 17
heures le directeur général de la santé
en première ligne au plus fort de la
crise sanitaire que ce qu'il fait c'est
avec les masques aurais tu aurais honte
ont pu sauver des vies notamment dans
les ehpad le confinement il était trop
tardif autant de questions sur la table
pour faire la lumière sur les
défaillances de la gestion de cette
crise
lors de son audition il s'est félicité
en tout cas de la réponse française à
l'épidémie je cherche cherche
désespérément un pays qui pourrait se
targuer d'avoir été prêt d'avoir
parfaitement géré cette pandémie compte
tenu du caractère totalement inédit
massif meurtrier brutal de cette
pandémie fait on a les agences
régionales de santé qui ont répondu aux
enjeux de surveillance et de réaction
rapide lorsque des premiers cas sont
survenus vraiment la réponse de terrain
a été de très haut niveau et pour en
parler nous sommes avec fabrice di vizio
avocat du collectif c 19 bonsoir fabrice
di vizio merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france vous êtes
justement à l'origine de plusieurs
plaintes 1 contre des responsables des
ministres dans cette affaire de gestion
du coc vide 19
quand vous entendez jérôme salomon
la réponse de terrain a été de haut
niveau par beaucoup de pays peuvent se
targuer en gros d'avoir géré aussi bien
quelle est votre réaction
ma réaction c'est d'abord d'être sûr
maintenant qu'on n'aura rien à attendre
cette commission denquête je le savais
mais maintenant j'en suis certain les
réponses qui ont été faites par jérôme
salomon je les écoutais un jérôme
salomon tout au long de sa pénible
interventions et bien jérôme salomon
parle de jérôme salle au monde jérôme
salomon félicite jérôme salomon mais
jérôme salomon à ne par là jamais des
victimes
jérôme salomon fait comme si elle pas eu
trente mille morts et jérôme simplement
oublie que juste à côté de chez nous par
exemple l'allemagne ça lui a été rappelé
plusieurs fois d'ailleurs au cours de la
commission a beaucoup mieux joué avec
nous donc il faut arrêter
jérôme salomon a envie de se féliciter
jérôme salomon m jérôme salomon mais
c'est tout ce que cette réponse a
rapporté finalement vous dit jérôme
saint amand jérôme sainement ils
défendent est aussi peut-être le
gouvernement est ce que c'est la faute
de jérôme salomon s'il n'y avait pas
assez de masse s'il n'y avait pas assez
de test alors ça c'est ce que l' enquête
devra montrer précisément mais en tout
cas ce que je sais c'est que jérôme
salomon est pour l'instant visé par une
enquête préliminaire du parquet et que
les réponses qui devra faire aux
officiers de police et qui plus est au
juge d'instruction
dès qu'une information judiciaire sera
ouverte seront d'un autre acabit seront
d'une autre envergure que celle qui l'a
fait devant la commission denquête
devant laquelle soyons clairs il est
chez lui
aujourd'hui on a assisté à un entre soi
on a assisté à la république qui
finalement d'un côté s'auto congratulent
et de l'autre fait semblant de poser des
questions qui fâchent
alors que fondamentalement celui à qui
elles sont posées a le loisir et le luxe
de ne pas y répondre
et bien moi je vous garantis pour
assister des clients régulièrement
devant le juge d'instruction que c'est
pas tout à fait comme ça que ça se passe
dans le cabinet d'un juge
alors le procureur françois molins salle
a annoncé aujourd'hui 84 plein temps au
total contre le gouvernement près de la
cour de justice
de la république dont la vôtre
d'ailleurs c'est vrai que ça fait
beaucoup 84 plainte
ça fait beaucoup mais il ya eu trente
mille morts meilleur c'est à dire qu'à
un moment donné et vous avez surtout un
gouvernement qui a menti de bout en bout
et si vous voulez ce genre d'attitude de
jérôme salomon arrogante suffisante ne
va pas arranger les choses
aujourd'hui les français vous avez vu
concrètement ce qui se passe votre
reportage l'a montré nous avons d'un
côté les manifestations de soignants qui
demande des réponses concrètes tangibles
et vous avez de l'autre une assemblée
nationale qui d'un côté s'auto
congratulent et de l'autre fait de la
politique politicienne
c'est plus possible sa plus aujourd'hui
ce que les français veulent ce que les
soignants veulent c'est des réponses
concrètes à des problèmes concrets ça
suffit le temps de l'autocongratulation
l'otan de l'autocongratulation pardon et
finalement le taux de l'autosuffisance
doit être terminé et c'est bien ça que
rappelle ces plaintes c'est un ras le
bol des français un ras-le-bol qu'on
leur mente un ras-le-bol qu'on dit c'est
de la faute d'un système mais finalement
c'est de la faute de personne comme si
le système se diriger tout seul il ya
qu'en france on voit ça ça suffit
maintenant
mais fabrice vision je me fais
évidemment l'avocat du diable ici mais
il n'y a pas un peu de vrai ce que c'est
pas cette lourdeur administrative de la
france qui vient d'être révélée dans
cette gestion de la crise du duc o vie
de 19 ans on sait tous que les masques
voilà aurait pu être commandées avant
ils n'ont pas été avant même le
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron
justement peut-être que ces personnes
trouvent tout simplement injuste d'être
visés pénalement et à titre finalement
personnel
enfin oui sans doute il ya une part de
responsabilités systémiques sans doute
mais maintenant concrètement c'est quand
même pas moins qu'ils aient reçu des
alertes au début janvier
c'est quand même pas le gouvernement de
marisol touraine ou françois hollande
qui a reçu effectivement des alertes
tout début janvier de la part de pékin
selon lesquelles un virus mortel
circulaient et qu' il allait être
mondiale enfin je veux dire c'est
exactement ce que dit agnès buzyn pardon
mais d'ailleurs jérôme salomon la plus
ou moins aujourd'hui confirmée on a des
alertes qui ont été donné très tôt
qu'est ce qu'on a fait est-ce qu'on a
réagi absolument pas regardez monsieur
véran par exemple au jour hier où je
sais plus comment semaine dernière
dans l'agora a dit que les généralistes
n'ont pas une masse que parce qu'ils
n'en avaient pas besoin
dans la mesure où ils n'ont pas vu de
patients enfin on sait tous que c'est
fou donc on sait tous que ces
gouvernements ont devant eux deux ment
regarder sans merci ni fabrice di vizio
que l' oms avait dit la même chose
effectivement sur les masques on en
n'avait pas forcément besoin au début
non non non l' oms a posé un débat sur
les masques grand public que je veux
bien admettre et c'est tout je vient
d'admettre avec une pointe de réserve
mais je veux mettre mes sur les
soignants le problème ne s'est jamais
posée absolument jamais mais sur ledit
public mais sur le public d'un autre
débat sur le public y a aucun débat sur
le fait que en plus en cas de pandémie
grippale par exemple nous avons des
plans qui suggère de manière constante
des masques pour le grand public
aujourd'hui on feint d'ignorer que
finalement il fallait des masques mais
c'est un peu de choses de rodez et de
prévu et l'om est ce effectivement n'a
jamais contredit la nécessité de masques
il a tempéré en disant que bon il
appartenait aux états de choisir en
fonction des éléments culturels
mais ensuite effectivement c'est à
l'état de décider fabrice di vizio à
propos des masques et les commandes
faites par l'état ne sont pas vraiment
transparente
on est donc le secret d'état dans ce cas
là on peut vraiment évoqué un secret
d'état sont ses commandes de masques
alors que les régions sont plutôt
transparente non c'est parfaitement
clair non j'ai le premier fait sommation
à olivier ferrand de nous donner la
copie des bons de commande et face à son
refus j'ai saisi la cour de shiso
république pour une raison simple c'est
qu'en fait aucun masque que n'a été
commandé
maintenant c'est une certitude et 2 fait
les bons de commande sont des documents
administratifs communicables c'est la
jurisprudence de la cad à venir à venir
évoquer le secret des affaires et d'une
supercherie intellectuelle qui justifie
les plaintes pénales et je ne comprends
pas que la commission denquête n'est pas
commencer par ça en exigeant les boums
commandes
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
la première réalité c'est quand même
d'exiger sur pièce la réalité de ce qui
a été fait et qu'on arrête des discours
inutiles
que pourrait-on en découvrir avec ses
bons de commande s'ils étaient publiées
dont on pourrait surtout découvrir
existe pas c'est surtout ça qu'on
pourrait découvrir c'est qu'en réalité
il n'ya pas eu de bons de commande je
pense qu'on va découvrir qu'en réalité
les banques commandes ont été
extrêmement tardif et que c'est la
raison pour laquelle on n'a pas réussi à
se procurer de masques je suis quasiment
sûre aujourd'hui au regard de la
réticence de l'état est au faîte du fait
qu'il est mal à l'aise à ce point qu'au
fond il ya une faille
il ya une défaillance sur ce point je le
dis depuis le premier jour il ya une
défaillance au niveau de l'état
s'agissant des masques et moi je suis
quasiment certain que ces masques ont
été commandés que extrêmement
tardivement et que c'est la raison pour
laquelle on donne autant de mal on a
autant de mal à les communiquer qu'est
ce que ça coûte de les communiquer ça ne
peut que rapporter gros de communiquer
les bons de commande
ça montre à quel point on a été
diligentée quel point c'est pas de notre
faute si on refuse quelque chose qui a
un tel bénéfice politique c'est que
nécessairement il ya un loup quelque
part ça briser le géoparc wa par
négligence par incompétence
on n'aurait pas commander ces masques en
temps et en heure locale est sans doute
par inconscience probablement parce que
quand j'entends olivier derand dire que
les généralistes net a besoin de masques
je me demande si on vit dans le même
groupe quand même et je me demande si
tout ça enfin une pointe de cynisme
lorsqu on sait qu effectivement des
médecins sont morts je me demande quand
même à quoi joue le gouvernement
et c'est bien pour ça je vais vous dire
que j'ai demandé moi officiellement
aujourd'hui à ce que les victimes soient
entendus que je représente soit entendu
par la commission d'enquêté
parlementaire
c'est pas une option c'est pas un débat
soit elle soit entendu soit la
commission d'enquêté parlementaire et
des saisies par une à part l'ouverture
d'une information judiciaire que je
provoquerais dès la semaine prochaine
merci fabrice indivision avocat du
collectif c 19 d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france la france doit-elle
débaptiser des rues et des monuments des
moules au nez des statuts au nom de
personnalités esclavagiste c'est ce que
réclame en tout cas plusieurs
associations et collectifs à paris d'un
statut de jean baptiste colbert devant
l'assemblée nationale a été prise pour
cible lors de la manifestation en
mémoire d'adama traoré ce 13 juin
alors jean baptiste colbert l'ancien
ministre du roi soleil qui fumaient
l'initiative en 585 du code noir qui a
légiféré l'esclavagisme doit tomber
boulonnais
sa statue qui trône en tête devant le
palais bourbon c'est l'objet de notre
face à face et pour en débattre nous
sommes en direct avec kevin bossuet
historiens à ses côtés ghislain vedobe
président du conseil représentatif des
associations noires de france bonsoir à
tous les deux merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france
estimez-vous légitime cette envie de
déboulonner ses statuts liés à
l'histoire coloniale on commence par
vous kevin bossuet si vous voulez c'est
parfaitement ridicule je veux dire
pourquoi déboulonner colbert enfin c'est
ridicule c'est à dire que tous ces gens
qui réclament le fait de déboulonner les
statues et notamment de déboulonner
colbert s'en prennent finalement au
peuple français s'en prenne à sa
civilisation s'en prenne à sa culture
s'en prennent à son identité et on
assiste en fait à une véritable guerre
culturelle notamment contre à l'encontre
de ce qui est la base notamment de la
culture et de la civilisation française
veut dire l'histoire de france elle est
riche histoire de france elle à ses
côtés parfois noires à lacets côté
parfois que leur but mais il faut
l'assumer tel quel puisque c'est ce qui
nous a permis d'être ce que nous sommes
aujourd'hui c'est à dire français geste
à un voeu de il faut assumer l'histoire
de france votre réponse il faut assumer
l'histoire de france mais surtout aussi
ce qu'il faut dire c'est qu'il faut
rappeler aussi le contexte historique
c'est à dire que colbert a été à le à
l'initiative de lait 2 du code noir le
code noir il faut le rappeler et c'était
ce document soit disant juridique qui
était censée régir les droits des noirs
qui étaient des esclaves et donc où ils
étaient considérés comme des objets des
biens meubles
c'était en 785 et donc effectivement la
france 2 785 n'est pas la france de 2020
aujourd'hui en 2020 on a besoin de héros
qui rassemble et pas de héros qui divise
tant qu'on aura à ce type de héros eh
bien on opposera des personnes qui
diront vos héros sont nos bourreaux et
bien puisque nous ne voulons pas des
héros qu'ils soient nos bourreaux
avons le devoir aujourd'hui de
construire ensemble en des héros qui
nous rassemble et non qui nous divise
kevin pense qu est-ce qu on peut
vraiment dire effectivement que colbert
est un symbole de l' esclavage c'est un
héros qui diviserait mais évidemment que
non je veux dire colbert c'est un
personnage historique important ne peut
pas le réduire seulement cotnoir
d'ailleurs j'y insiste sur le fait qu'il
n'a pas à l'écrit le code noir un
colbert c'était un grand ministre de
louis xiv c'est quelqu'un qui est à
l'origine que l'état moderne c'est
quelqu'un qui a à l'origine du code
forestier c'est quelqu'un qui a un
initiateur notamment de la masse de la
manufacture des gobelins et c'est tout
cela que l'on salue à travers que de
bercy il ya une statue colbert devant
l'assemblée nationale en fait on honore
le serviteur de l'état français ce n'est
pas autre chose et voir à travers cette
statue notamment une glorification de l'
esclavage est évidemment ridicule la
vérité c'est que tous ces militants qui
réclament cela non je le répète qu'une
seule volonté s'en prendre à l'identité
française parce qu'il n'aime pas ce
qu'est la france
on est véritablement dans l' envie de
remplacer une culture par une autre et
c'est dramatique et moi j'insiste
beaucoup si vous voulez sur le mouvement
antiraciste enfin moi je trouve ça
scandaleux
ces gens prétendent lutter contre le
raciste alors qu'ils ne font finalement
que promouvoir la distinction des races
fins et c'est horrible nous sommes
français
nous sommes unis autour d'une histoire
nous sommes unis autour de valeurs les
valeurs et moi je n'accepte pas que des
gens salissent notre histoire
lg c'est un wagon je vais vous laisser
répondre effectivement il ya plusieurs
idées combat identitaire distinction des
races les personnes comme vous puisque
vous êtes visées ont voulu occulter ce
que vous êtes pour déboulonner sais tu
sais tu n'aimerais pas la france quelle
est votre réponse
et bien simplement c'est un débat c'est
un dialogue ce n'est pas un soliloque
donc cela signifie qu'aujourd'hui il
faut prendre en compte la france
d'aujourd'hui la france 2020 ça veut
dire quoi
c'est à dire que la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est raconter l'histoire de
france dans son entièreté et l'offre
l'histoire de france dans son entièreté
c'est quoi savez vous madame et
messieurs
quelle était la capitale de la france
libre là
talent de la france libre entre 40 et 44
c'était brazzaville au congo
c'est aussi ça l'histoire de france
l'histoire de france c'est aussi le fait
d'avoir mis en place en 1804 81 le code
de l'indigénat le code de l'indigénat
qui a été abolies en 1946 par houphouët
boigny au foie d'oie nick était premier
président de côte d'ivoire et qui était
ministre français sur la troisième
république
c'est ça l'histoire de france qu'il faut
rappeler aussi donc quand nous rappelons
que oui il est temps de mettre ses
statuts et tous de mettre toutes ses
oeuvres dans des musées parce
qu'aujourd'hui elles sont vandalisés et
on pense qu'elle elles auraient leur
place dans des musées et au delà de cela
c'est qu'il faut faire un travail
pédagogique aujourd'hui dans nos écoles
l'année dernière encore on enseigner
dans les écoles à nantes par exemple les
bienfaits de la colonisation
eh bien il n'y a pas de bienfaits de la
colonisation la colonisation et
l'esclavagé des crimes
c'est des meurtres et des viols c'est un
crime contre l'humanité et donc
aujourd'hui nous avons besoin de
construire des héros qui rassemble et au
delà de ça parce qu'on ne va pas se
cacher derrière les statuts ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui
les statuts sont des symboles mais que
se passe-t-il au delà des statuts c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le racisme et les
discriminations ne sont pas à
sanctionner c'est ça le problème
c'est ça le problème fondamental le
défenseur des droits la cncdh le comité
consultatif des droits de l'homme
rendent des rapports tous les ans où il
ya des discriminations à l'emploi des
discriminations logement les 10 nations
à l'accès à la santé et des formations à
la formation c'est ça qui se passe
aujourd'hui est justement qu'est-ce
qu'il qu'est-ce qui se passe wolf les
noirs et les arabes ont vingt fois plus
de risques d'être d'être violentée par
la police de mourir sous les coups des
policiers
quel est le lien quel lien faites
fait-on entre les violences policières
et les statuts et bien c'est le mal être
de notre société
et quand des populations ne sont pas
comptés répandent on va desserrer ne
sont pas entendus les bien et réagit
certains débats donc on va à l'essai
répondre il ya cette idée effectivement
de nécessité peut-être de de réviser
l'histoire qui serait parfois pas bien
enseigné entre guillemets en tout cas
mal enseignée vous le prof d'histoire
qu'est ce que vous répondez
à cela ghislain le dos kévin bru et
pardon oui l'histoire l'église et
d'histoire vous l'acceptez telle qu'elle
est et j'entends qu'on en oublierait une
partie de l'histoire mais là on parle d'
esclavage nous parle toujours de l'
esclavage notamment de la traite
atlantique c'est à dire qui est né au
xvième siècle et qui a concerné en effet
les blancs et les noirs mais moi
j'aimerais rappeler qu'il ya pas cette
forme là d' esclavage à partir du 7ème
ou 8ème siècle après jésus-christ gab et
notamment la traite arabe
vous aviez des populations arabes qui
ont mis en esclavage notamment des
populations africaines j'aimerais aussi
rappeler qu'il ya une traite intra
africaines où vous avez des populations
noires qui se sont mis eux-mêmes en
esclavage donc si on est un petit peu
honnête il faut peut-être rappeler cela
après j'aimerais insister sur un point
également à les y fait normal vivra pas
échangé je voulais vous faire aussi
écouter emmanuel macron parce que c'est
important
il affirme le président tout cas que la
république n'effacera aucun nom et
aucune trace de son histoire écoutez je
vous le dis très clairement ce soir mes
chers compatriotes la république
n'effacera aucune trace ni aucun nom de
son histoire
elle n'oubliera aucune de ses oeuvres
elle ne déboulonnera pas de statut nous
devons plutôt lucidement regarder
ensemble toute notre histoire
toutes nos mémoires notre rapport à
l'afrique en particulier pour bâtir un
présent et un avenir possible d'une rive
à l'autre de la méditerranée avec une
volonté de vérité et en aucun cas de
revisiter ou de nier ce que nous sommes
en fin de non recevoir du président de
la république kevin bossuet je vous
laisserai finir votre pensée tout à
l'heure mais je voulais faire réagir
justement ghislain veut d'eux essayez
d'être court 1 messieurs pour que vous
puissiez un petit peu échangé sur les
deux dernières minutes
j'ai cela veut tout simplement il faut
rappeler que emmanuel macron est
complètement à côté de la plaque
il est complètement éloigné des réalités
de ce pays parce que justement ce n'est
pas lui qui décide si on doit
déboulonner les statues ou pas et bien
c'est le peuple français et qu'il décide
il faut qu emmanuel macron se rappelle
qu'il a été élu
il est élu par un peuple justement ce
peuple rappelle qu en guadeloupe et en
martinique aujourd'hui il ya des
personnes 90 % de la population sont
contaminés au chlordécone la commission
d enquête parlementaire qui a eu lieu
l'année dernière elle a mis en avant
cela aussi haut aussi à en guadeloupe
toujours il ya un hôpital qui est brûlé
et bien que la république s'en occupe
moi je suis d'accord qu'il faut il
fallait qu'on raconte toute notre
histoire
eh bien oui il faudra compter aussi que
la capitale la france libre eh bien oui
c'était brazzaville il faut aussi
raconté on l'a dit tout à l'heure que ce
qui s'est passé aussi c'est que la
police nationale française est l'aîné
sous le régime de vichy en 1941
c'est ça l'histoire de france eh bien il
faut raconter cette histoire dans son
entièreté
et il faut aussi rappeler ce qui s'est
passé en haïti en guadeloupe en
martinique il faudrait raconter
l'histoire dans son entièreté kevin
dessus est effectivement peut-être pas
éradiqué mais expliqué il ya quand même
cette nécessité d'expliquer l'histoire
c'est évident il faut expliquer
l'histoire mais faut absolument
absolument pas effacer l'histoire moi je
n'ai vu j'en ai entendu aucun juif
vouloir effacer à auschwitz où il est
facile de dire que nous tout simplement
parce que ça serait ça serait effacé la
mémoire de ses victimes il y a eu en
effet dans notre histoire de l'esclavagé
c'est quelque chose de regrettable c'est
quelque chose d' abjecte sans doute
parce qu'on ait fait c'était quelque
chose d'horrible mais de là il ne faut
pas effacer les traces de cet esclavage
plutôt essayer de faire un travail de
mémoire mettre en avant des explications
essayer de comprendre ce qui s'est passé
à l'époque pour ne pas reproduire ce
qu'on a fait par le passé
moi ce qui me scandalise si vous voulez
c'est que j'ai en face de moi quelqu'un
qui ne s'empêtre dans le giron
républicain
il remet en cause la légitimité des
manuels macron qui est le président de
la république française et qui a été élu
par une majorité de français moi je suis
désolé emmanuel macron représente la
france représente les français la police
républicaine représente la france
représente les français représentent la
république et je ne laisserai pas des
gens par pure idéologie cracher sur mon
pays ait craché sur ce qui devrait tous
nous rassembler c'est à dire la
république merci kevin je suis et merci
à vous également j cela un vélo d'avoir
accepté
le débat je vous laisse une seconde je
vois que vous m'ont vraiment vite parce
qu'on arrive à la fin on arrive à la fin
peut-on imaginer aujourd'hui peut-on
imaginer aujourd'hui que parce que la
france a été envahi pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale
café hitler il est venu se pavaner
devant le trocadéro et bien peut-on
imaginer aujourd'hui qui est une statue
devant le trocadéro pour rappeler cette
histoire
eh bien non et pourtant peut-on imaginer
aujourd'hui qu'ils aient une vie une
statue de pétain à vichy
et bien non plus donc cette histoire et
les rappeler elle est enseignée c'est
une histoire à l'école et donc il est
temps de mettre tout ça dans des musées
et d'enseigner cela pédagogiquement avec
merci steve
merci à tous les deux cette fois ci
c'est la fin merci dans quelques
instants rester avec nous nous parlerons
de l'afrique la banque mondiale qui
prévoit une chute de plus de 23% des
transferts d'argent conséquence directe
de l'épidémie de coronavirus et puis
direction de vieux continent bruxelles
ouvre deux enquêtes contre la firme
américaine apple pour des soupçons de
comportement anticoncurrentiel
[Musique]
si on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on me vois pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce coup ci c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
nous recevons pauline d'orgeval
présidente et cofondatrice de kohat
petit santé le pratiquent même de notre
association c'est de réduire les
inégalités d'accès à la santé et d'accès
aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc finissent par
renoncer aux soins vous avez proposé
deux posters en falck ça que ça veut
dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
pour construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
bonsoir merci nous rejoindre en direct
sur rt france les conséquences
économiques du communisme se font
ressentir partout dans le monde de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée les
transferts d'argent de la diaspora
africaine présente en europe devrait
connaître un recul de plus de 20% cette
année selon la banque mondiale
un véritable coup dur pour les
populations locales t au combat si belle
à tamba et ghislain mais non ça pour les
explications on côte d'ivoire dans un
des quartiers commerçants de la capitale
économique abidjan
edwige boni ouvre comme d'habitude les
portes de son salon de coiffure à ses
clientes
problème ces dernières sont devenus
rares en cette période de crise
sanitaire
une diminution de l'activité qui touche
de nombreux entrepreneurs du pays
d'habitude pour éponger ses charges
fixes et verser des salaires de son
personnel
edwige a recours au transfert d'argent
provenant de ses proches qui résident en
europe
mais depuis plusieurs semaines ses
revenus complémentaires vitaux pour elle
comme pour de nombreux autres
commerçants se sont taries avant j'ai re
semaine mais les rangs maintenant je
reçois à 500 euros ou 300 euros
ils m'ont dit qu'ils ne travaillent pas
et qui perçoivent plus de
de saleh donc c'est le peu qu'ils
avaient qu'ils m'envoient pour faire
preuve de ses difficultés
la jeune femme vient retirer de l'argent
envoyé par sa famille en france
mais la somme est largement inférieure à
ce qu'elle reçoit normalement
une situation qui à terme lui fait
craindre de graves difficultés
financières
vraiment c'est parce qu'ils ne voient
tout ce que j'ai reçu
car 70000 autant pas par rapport à avant
c'était parce que gérer ses biens gérés
s'élevait plus que ça passe et la femme
et ma paie mon loyer
donc je pense que ça ne serait pas
comment je sais pas comment est ce qu'on
va vivre une perte de revenus pour
nombre d'ivoiriens que déplore aussi ce
gérant des agences de transfert d'argent
avant par exemple quand on recevait les
clients sur 20 clients qu henri saivet
par jour on pouvait avoir les clients
qui venaient pour des montants de 2000
euros 3000 euros de 1500 euros
mais maintenant les clients qui viennent
soit 7 300 euros 200 euros 250 euros
parfois même 50 euros pour cet
économiste
en cas de prolongement de la crise
sanitaire c'est toute une partie de la
population qui risque de se retrouver
précariser les transferts des migrants
soit une source de financement
importante pour les familles dans la
mesure où ces familles là utilisent ces
transferts non seulement pour tout ce
qui concerne l'alimentation l'éducation
et potentiellement pour des
investissements au niveau des
différentes sags ont donc il est vrai
que
il est possible qu'on parte vers des
situations de précarité pour de
nombreuses populations
si la situation inquiète grandement une
maîtrise de la pandémie suivi d'une
reprise totale de l'économie pourrait
changer la donne un retour au monde
d'avant souhaité par edwige et
l'ensemble du pays dont la croissance
devrait ralentir de plus de 4% en 2020
selon le fmi
et pour en parler nous sommes avec un
maïs mi6 analystes économiques bonsoir
avec celui-ci merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france
la banque mondiale qui prévoit donc une
chute de plus de 23% des français faire
d'argent vers l'afrique
quelles conséquences selon vous les
transferts de la diaspora et cannes vers
le continent sont relativement
importants ces transferts forts
généralement utilisés à des fins de
subsistance donc la conséquence de
l'interruption de la réduction du volume
de transfert sera d'abord conséquences
sociales pour les personnes qui les
retours avec ils vont voir leur revenu
de subsistance betty la deuxième
conséquence sera une conséquence au
volant économique du point de vue de la
consommation qui sera diversement
appréciée dans le pays selon les pays
parce que nos volumes de transfert du
point de vue monétaire n'est pas le même
en fonction des des pays impliqués dans
lesquelles on se trouve donc ça va être
premièrement une conséquence pour
ferrals et deuxièmement une qu'on est
comme une conséquence économique qui
découlerait de la baisse de la
consommation de ces ménages qui
viendraient amplifié les effets de la
crise que nous avons déjà observé
est ce qu'on peut imaginer également des
pertes d'emplois de salaires à partir du
moment où il y à un ralentissement de
l'économie du fait de la baisse de la
consommation
on peut effectivement on sait qu'il aura
des répercussions beaucoup plus large y
compris au niveau des emplois mais il
faut bien garder à l'esprit que la
baisse des transferts de la diaspora
africaine perles ou continent sera un
élément de la crise globale que nous
certainement pas d'élément majeur mais
un élément en amplifiant parce que la
crise en elle même par les conséquences
du coup vide les conséquences de
confinement l'eau pour lui des
conséquences du ralentissement général
de l'activité économique a déjà eu des
défaites n'est pas ne serait ce que sur
l'emploi sur le chômage est également
sur les revenus des différents états
donc il faut inscrire notamment un cadre
macroéconomique globale à l'échelle de
tous les pays du continent
et on peut penser que globalement les
conséquences sociales et économiques
seront assez grave et l'année 2000 bord
battre continuer bête je pense une année
assez difficile
la roma - beaucoup plus tard justement
quelles sont les solutions selon vous
puisque les états africains ont besoin
de 105 milliards d'euros pour faire face
à cette crise c'est ce qu'indique en
tout cas là la bancaire mondial les
promesses des dons extérieurs nets
atteignent que 65 millions de dollars
pour l'instant je pense qu'on ne
développe pas des pays encore moins
contenant par des dons ne pense que il
est à des circuits économiques pratiques
ou relancer une économie ou financer une
économie généralement en prenant une
économie par l'investissement par la
consommation qui sont arrivés à faire en
sorte que dès lors que nous serons
sortis de cette phase était particulière
et difficile
en plus de permettre aux états d'avoir
des lectures qui permette de relancer
véritablement l'investissement dans les
pays par l'investissement va créer de
l'emploi on va créer de la croissance et
il faut trouver des moyens par des
politiques pas de par des politiques
sociales pour irriguer des canaux de
façon à accroître la consommation
consommation qui fera elle tourner
l'économie et donc générera aussi de
l'emploi
je pense que cet arc et que l'on voit
uniquement par le spectre des dons c'est
une afrique du passé pour aller dans le
développement que blood inspirant et
fils d'africains attendent
il faut pas me font penser aux
politiques d'investissements qui seront
décidées par les africains tenté par
débarquer qu'un pour les africains
est-ce que c'est finalement l'occasion
pour l'afrique d'être un tournant
justement de son destin et de se
réinventer comme vous dites je pense
effectivement que certains pays du
continent
vivement les conséquences de la prise du
pouls vide vont pouvoir réinventer
certains aspects de leur économie
parce que qu'est-ce que la prise d'epo
vite nous apprend des points de vue
économique première avant eux beaucoup
de pays africains sont aujourd'hui
construit avec des économies qui sont
extrêmement extraverti et dès lors il ya
encore quelque part sur la planète on a
dit en europe ou en amérique par effet
consulter les pays africains se trouvent
directement impactés donc il va falloir
commencer je crois à construire un
véritable marché à pékin dépassant à ce
que nous sommes nous avions beaucoup
plus autonome beaucoup plus dingues
interdépendants au sein de la peep est
beaucoup plus d'indépendance vis-à-vis
des autres parties du continent de façon
à avoir une économie beaucoup plus en
plus une économie beaucoup plus
résiliente qui permettrait au continent
d'affronter les crises avec on va dire
une meilleure armature économique est
beaucoup plus d'eux nous sommes les
pieds de sow limité que certains d'état
vont en tirer les conséquences mais
évidemment certainement pas tous merci
mais il sait me 6 analystes économiques
de nous avoir apporté votre analyse ce
soir apple face à la commission
européenne bruxelles annonce aujourd'hui
avoir ouvert plusieurs enquêtes contre
la marque à la pomme
la commission européenne soupçonne le
géant américain de pratiques anti
concurrentielles notamment sur le marché
de la musique en ligne du livre audio ou
des services de paiement électronique
de son côté la firme de copertino se
défend de tout abus de position
dominante
il est décevant que la commission
européenne avance des plaintes infondées
de la part d'une poignée d'entreprises
qui veulent simplement profiter de la
situation sans payer ni jouer selon les
mêmes règles que le reste du monde nous
ne pensons pas que ce soit juste
nous voulons maintenir des conditions de
concurrence équitables ou toute personne
déterminée ayant une idée prometteuse
peut prospérer et pour ans
parlez nous sommes avec olivier iteanu
avocat spécialiste du droit numérique
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france des enquêtes ouvertes que
peut-on en attendre
écoutez apple arrive après une série d'
enquêtes ouvertes par des différentes
autorités de régulation de la
concurrence juste avant de confinement
france avant mi mars à la fin de l'année
2019 on a eu d'autorité de la
concurrence qui a condamné google à 150
millions d'euros
la réalité c'est quoi c'est que c'est
sega femmes puisque apple fait partie de
lega femmes google apple facebook et
amazon et on peut ajouter microsoft en
fait sont des oligopoles sont à nos
digues open se sont chacun des monopoles
quand on entend le communiqué de presse
de la société apple c'est une blague
non seulement ils sont là en position
dominante alors la bu ça c'est une
enquête qu'il dira me sont en position d
l'ont dit ils sont en position
monopolistique et l'europe est un une
des seule région au monde où ces
entreprises disposent d'un tel monopole
alors effectivement quand on est
surpuissant on a plus d'obligation et
notamment des obligations pour permettre
à la petite concurrence qui subsiste de
faire également son trou voilà donc ces
enquêtes ne sont pas une surprise à
vienne très tard elles viennent très
très tard toute la vague du numérique
nouvelles générations arrivées avec
google qui a été créée en 1998 aux états
unis regrettent arrivée en europe en
2003 facebook en 2005 twitter en 2007
en réalité très peu de ces sociétés ont
été poursuivis condamné pour des
problèmes de concurrence
mais maintenant des choses s'enchaînent
je dirais qu'on est dans une deuxième
phase qui paraît totalement logique
peut-être un peu tard mais l'europe a
tellement de challenge à relever dans le
monde du numérique
il n'est pas mauvais que l'on rappelle
des règles équitables et justes que
réclame apple elles doivent être pour
tout le monde et c'est jean-pierre smith
n'a été peu david contre goliath
tout de même est ce que l'europe a les
moyens tout simplement de s'attaquer aux
gaffes à surpuissant alors david et
goliath vous avez raison mais sur le
plan de la régulation de la
réglementation c'est simplement une
question de volonté ya pas être goliath
ou david et c'est simplement une
question de volonté
il faut enquêter et lorsque ces
entreprises ont eu des pratiques qui ont
empêché les solutions alternatives
européennes d'émerger parce que regarder
bien est ce qu on a véritablement
beaucoup de solution alternative à
google à apple à facebook et amazon
on en a mais elles ont dû elles ont du
mal elle peine à exister et souvent en
tout cas c'est ma conviction souvent
c'est aussi par le fait des pratiques de
ces entreprises et donc c'est pas
étonnant que la commission européenne
ouvre une telle enquête encore une fois
et on en attend beaucoup
quand on est véritablement un supporter
de l'europe
et lorsque est toujours est
effectivement pénalisant pour les
européens c'est cette contre attaque de
la part des gaffes a notamment sur
l'emploi ce qu'il ya un risque à ce
niveau là quand on s'attaque un peu trop
près justement assez puissant bah écoute
et effectivement c'est un peu la clé du
problème c'est à dire que ces
entreprises ont investi le l'europe
on commence à créer des emplois bien
qu'ils aient des études qui montrent
c'est peut-être pas tant d'emplois que
ça mais c'est une réalité économique
elle apporte quand même elle crée on va
dire des richesses en europe
alors effectivement ce chantage il faut
bien une fois bien appeler par son nom
existe on en a eu encore une
illustration avec amazon
lorsque la justice française s'est
plainte et lui a demandé de fermer ses
locaux car elle est bien est en tout cas
apparemment ceux des entrepôts tels
qu'ils étaient exploités crée des
difficultés pour un des salariés
oui mais quand il faut que l'europe soit
assis sur ses valeurs
car derrière la réglementation qui
paraît tati renière la régulation il ya
des valeurs
faut bien voir ça et les gars femmes
elles avancent toujours avec un discours
très ouvert très cool attitude
mais je peux vous assurer que des
entreprises européennes aux états unis
quand elles ne respectent pas les règles
communes elles sont sanctionnées et il
faut qu'en europe les choses soient
soient identiques
il n'y a pas de raison qu'elle soit en
dehors des lois quelle est la finalité
finalement que risque
apple et qu'est ce qu'a justement ces
entreprises européennes en telle qu'est
ce qu'elles ont à gagner dans cette
affaire je connais pas des détails de
cette affaire mais probablement que
apple évoque dans son communiqué de
presse un groupe d'entreprises
donc ce sont probablement des sociétés
qui sont en situation de concurrence
partiellement évidemment car on connaît
pas d'européens qui soit exactement
concurrents d'apple ça n'existe pas mais
qui probablement sur des niches vous
avez évoqué la musique et bien ont
quelques difficultés vis-à-vis des
pratiques d'apple
vous savez très souvent ces grandes
entreprises elle dispose d'une
trésorerie colossal de moyens colossaux
et elles investissent un secteur
d'activité qui est assez délimité en
cassant les prix
en faisant en proposant des avantages
considérables dans le seul but de rompre
de casser de briser la concurrence je
crois que c'est ça que la commission
européenne va étudier
c'est à dire cet équilibre à savoir si
apple sur des petits marchés pertinents
n'a pas abusé de sa position dominante
c'est très bien qu'elle ne fasse
merci olivier était à nu d'avoir été
avec nous en des lectures rt france
compte réduire le nombre de militaires
américains stationnés en allemagne alors
effective sera divisé par 2 du coup cela
restera un engagement américain au
niveau européen dans le cadre de l'otan
est pour le président
ricains berlin ne contribue pas assez à
son budget
nous avons 52 mille soldats en allemagne
ça fait énormément de soldats c'est un
coup énorme pour les états unis et
l'allemagne comme vous le savez est très
en retard dans ses paiements à l'otan
l'allemagne à des arriérés ça fait des
années qu'ils ont des arriérés
ils doivent des milliards de dollars à
l'otan et il faut qu'il paie si nous
protégeons l'allemagne et ils ont des
arriérés c'est ridicule est un coup dur
pour les relations entre les deux pays
un camouflet pour berlin je vous propose
d'écouter la réaction du ministre
allemand des affaires étrangères
nous pensons que la présence américaine
en allemagne est importante pour la
sécurité non seulement de l'allemagne
mais aussi pour la sécurité des états
unis et particulièrement pour la
sécurité de l'europe les etats-unis ont
également indiqué clairement que la
manière et le moment exact de la mise en
oeuvre de cette décision et ne sont pas
encore décidé et je pense donc qu'il est
important que nous ayons maintenant un
dialogue au sein de l'otan sur cette
question s'agit d'un accord bilatéral
entre les états unis et l'allemagne
mais il est bien sûr important pour
l'ensemble de l'alliance
au mozambique à présent l'omg les amis
de la terre accuse le projet de total
d'exploitation de gaz dans l'isère la
planète entière un peu plus dans la
crise climatique et ainsi d'attiser des
tensions dans la région un projet
pourtant validé par l'exécutif français
dès les qualifs à faire du profit sur le
dos de l'écologie c'est en gros ce que
reproche l'organisation les amis de la
terre à la france pour reprendre leur
terme exact la france est accusée
d'amorcer une bon climatique au
mozambique et plus précisément le groupe
français total qui développe un méga
projet d'exploitation de gaz naturel
les pouvoirs publics français se soient
activés depuis plusieurs années pour que
les industriels du gaz et leurs
banquiers profitent de l'eldorado gazier
à 60 milliards de dollars au mozambique
contribuant ainsi à enfoncer le pays
dans la dépendance aux énergies fossiles
le nom du rapport est plutôt explicite
de l'eldorado gazier au chaos quand la
france poussent le mozambique dans le
piège du gaz
prenons le temps de faire un peu de
géographie vous le voyez sur cette carte
le mozambique a découvert au début des
années 2010 de vastes réserves sous
marines au large de ses côtes nord dans
l'océan indien
estimé à 5000 milliards de mètres cubes
elles doivent transformer un des pays
les plus pauvres de la planète en un
exportateur de gaz naturel liquéfié de
tout premier plan
emmanuel macron n'a pas manqué de le
rappeler en janvier dernier le
mozambique découvre qu'il a des
formidable gisement dans ses eaux
territoriales
il est en train de les exploiter
d'ailleurs avec parfois des opérateurs
français la difficulté qu'on aura
collectivement c'est d'expliquer à des
pays pauvres qui découvrent des
gisements
comment il va falloir se passer de ces
hydrocarbures
il va falloir trouver des compensations
dans l'économie internationale pour les
aider à en sortir et les rendre moins
dépendant de cela des paroles qui ne
vont pas empêcher les lobbys industriels
de mettre la pression au gouvernement
français pour que ces ressources
fossiles soit exploité à leur profit au
détriment de l'environnement et de
l'humain oui car exploiter ces gisements
revient à l'équivalent de sept heures
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
là
france voilà pour le volet écologique
pas son volet guérilla ces fameuses
réserves de gaz sont situées dans la
province mozambicaine du cabo delgado
théâtre depuis deux ans et demi d'une
insurrection islamiste qui a fait plus
de 1100 morts conséquence la population
civile est prise en otage entre les
remous politiques internes et
l'installation de multinationales qui
déplace des familles entières de
pêcheurs et d'agriculteurs
et pour finir on ajoute à ça que le
littoral abrite une incroyable
biodiversité en danger à cause de ces
projets gaziers
les amis de la terre appellent le
gouvernement français à mettre un point
d'arrêt à la diplomatie du chaos au
service des industriels des énergies
fossiles et de l'armement en commençant
par cesser de leur octroyer des aides
publiques à l'exportation
au vu de la gravité des violations des
droits humains des risques
environnementaux et climatiques
il somme les entreprises françaises
impliquées banques privées comme crédit
agricole et société générale
industrielle de l'énergie comme total de
se retirer des projets gaziers au large
du mozambique et de renoncer à tout
développement de nouveaux projets pour
revenir sur un dernier chiffre 60
milliards de dollars c'est
l'investissement estimé dans cette
région par l'industrie fossile soit
quatre fois le pib du mozambique en 2019
des chiffres qui ne font pas reculer les
amis de la terre violations des droits
humains corruption destruction des
écosystèmes
le message est passé reste à savoir s'il
sera entendu ou si une fois de plus
l'écologie humaine et environnementale
sera sacrifié sur l'autel du profit et
c'est la fin de cette émission se
retrouve à 22 heures pile pour un point
complet sur l'actualité
il est
[Musique]
il est évident qu'avec le coc vider avec
ce qui s'est passé alors là on va
atteindre plutôt de gens sous employés
ou au chômage qui vont être des liens
dans un horizon relativement court on va
voir effectivement le taux de chômage
exploser en france il ya un grand nombre
de mesures qui sont aujourd'hui déployés
et puis aussi des concertations qui sont
en cours avec les partenaires sociaux
auxquels ces salons vont les bonnes
mesures
c'est pas l'état quitterait les postes
nous rappelle ces les entreprises et les
gouvernements successifs ont bien
compris que sur le marché du travail
il fallait soutenir la création
d'emplois par les entreprises un
malheureusement on va payer tous
collectivement l'incompétence de nos
dirigeants
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je suis
finissent par renoncer au soir vous avez
proposé deux posters en falck salle que
ça veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
pour construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce que si c'est interdit d'interdire
l'histoire est plus compliquée que
certains veulent le faire croire
vouloir à la réécrire pour faire oublier
les échecs ne permet pas de comprendre
ce qui s'est vraiment passé
c'est ainsi que dans certains manuels de
cours d'histoire de nos enfants on veut
faire oublier napoléon bonaparte grand
organisateur de l'état moderne pour
profit de robespierre
le père de la terreur j'ai écouté le
président en train de pratiquer le déni
en oubliant carrément l'allier qui a eu
le triste privilège d'avoir le plus
grand nombre de morts dans la deuxième
guerre mondiale
mais si j'ai bien compris ils sont morts
pour rien puisque au nom d'une idéologie
on nie leur existence en oubliant une
partie de la game
je
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un font 42
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie une catastrophe
ça veut dire à côté qatar ce trop fine
il ya un tournant mais on re se remet à
vivre mais dans une autre direction
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais telle une décision à
vraisemblable pour vous ça dépend telles
valeurs on attribue à la mort et à la
vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie revient
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
moral un débat éthique
et
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
mondiale quel rôle doit selon vont jouer
à levin et quel rôle joue-t-elle dans
les faits les villes tout comme les
états ils n'étaient pas préparés
mais les villes elles se sont connectés
tout de suite entre elles pour voir
comment elles pouvaient coopérer
il ya eu l'envoi des beaucoup de des
masques de matériels médicaux d'une
commune à l'autre selon vous à quoi
pourront rassembler les îles comment
est-ce qu'elles vont se transformer
après la pandémie la crise maintenant à
fait bien comprendre qu'on peut pas
s'oublier des banlieues on peut pas
oublier les quartiers pauvres parce que
véritablement être en partie de la vie
donc les grandes villes quand il se
connecte
elle ne parle pas seulement d'elle-même
elle parle aussi de comment créer cette
cercle vertueux avec les villes des
alentours
[Musique]
ça fait maintenant plusieurs je dirais
décennies presque que la france ou
financent sa recherche et son
enseignement supérieur à quoi est-ce que
vous attribuez ce manque de moyens c'est
un un problème politique au sens où ça
serait pas beau devant le projet
politique
la grande cherche n'a pas la place
qu'elles devraient avoir parce que la
recherche est un élément central dans la
prise en compte et très très grand défi
auquel nous sommes et en particulier le
défi québec ses conséquences et
notamment les problèmes ni là c'est la
première mais qui va y en avoir d'autres
il faut qu'ils aient une prise de
conscience collective vraiment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on a une idée d'augmentation
ou pas défini ci d'aujourd'hui en france
l'écho et les violences existait avant
le confinement et pendant ce compliment
c'est vrai qu'il ya sept ce cadre
lecture les taux de féminicide a plus
que j'étais pas doublé mais bien monté
forcément on n'a pas encore tous les
chiffres officiels c'est très difficile
bourreau n'est jamais d âme et loi
finalement c'est le confinement dans le
confinement
cela veut dire qu'il ya huit clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément donc les femmes victimes de
violences de nombreux endroits à 3
[Musique]
des dizaines de milliers de soignants
dont dix-huit mille à paris dans la rue
après les promesses du président
mettront objectif obtenir des actes
concrets en plein c ur de la santé à
paris le cortège parti du ministère de
la santé a été émaillée d'échauffourées
au niveau de l'esplanade des invalides
et forces de l'ordre ont fait usage de
gaz lacrymogène on compte 24
interpellations
une journée marquée également par
l'ouverture de la commission d' enquête
parlementaire à l'assemblée sur les
gestions ducobu première à être
auditionné cet après midi jérôme c'est
le mans qui affirme que la réponse de
terrain était de haut niveau
le couperet est tombé et pékin referme
toutes les écoles et appelle ses
habitants ne pas quitter les villes en
cause une résurgence de 4 covin la
mairie à verte d'une situation
extrêmement grave alors que plus d'une
centaine de personnes ont été
contaminées depuis la semaine dernière
dans la capitale chinoise
la mégalopole de 21 millions d'habitants
emportés sa capacité quotidienne de
sage plus de 90000 personnes
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france
mobilisation nationale des soignants
dans tout le pays les plaies donc les
français qui ont les ont applaudis
ces trois derniers mois les rejoindre
dans la rue en première ligne pendant la
crise sanitaire et après les promesses
des manuels macron le personnel de santé
veut des actes alors que se joue en ce
moment le ségur de la santé pour une
refonte du système hospitalier
à paris où l'on dénombre 18 mille
manifestants des échauffourées ont
éclaté en marge du cortège
plusieurs centaines de manifestants
habillés en noir ont mis le feu du
mobilier jeté des projectiles et forces
de l'ordre ont répondu par des tirs de
lacrymogènes en compte 24
interpellations les précisions sur place
de notre reporter nadège abderrazak ils
étaient des dizaines de milliers de
médecins d'infirmiers et
d'aides-soignants à s'être mobilisés
aujourd'hui pour demander plus de moyens
à l'hôpital public et cela en pleine
période de ségur de la santé cette vaste
concertation et qui doit déboucher d'ici
au mois de juillet un plan pour
l'hôpital a parmi les revendications on
retrouve une augmentation à
significative des salaires des créations
poste mais aussi l arrêt des fermetures
d'établissements de lits et de service
je vous propose justement est d'écouter
certains manifestants actuellement les
hôpitaux son manque de matériel en
manque d'effectif ça je le dis haut et
fort on se retrouve maintenant avec des
dents des services avec 23 patients pour
un an ferme et une étonnante je trouve
ça inadmissible
donc nous on est épuisé on n'est pas
écoutés on se sent délaissée c'est la
seule motivation de les gens qui étaient
très nombreux demande ministère de la
santé toujours une manifestation
autorisée par la préfecture de police de
paris qui a pris son départ depuis le
ministère de la santé
manifestants avaient pour ambition de
continuer à manifester jusqu'à
l'assemblée nationale et ça n'a pas été
possible puisque cette manifestation et
qui a plutôt bien commencé et est devenu
le théâtre de violents affrontements sur
l'esplanade des invalides entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre à des
manifestants qui ont été infiltrés par
plusieurs centaines d'individus cagoulés
habillés de noir qui se sont déplacés
pour en découdre avec les forces de
l'ordre
viser à part de nombreux jets de
projectiles les forces de l'ordre ont
répondu à coups de gaz lacrymogènes par
coups de matraque également plusieurs
dizaines de personnes ont été blessés
dans les deux camps chez les
manifestants chez elle et forces de
police
trente deux personnes ont été
interpellées du mobilier urbain a été
dégradé des voitures ont été retournées
des poubelles incendiées ah voilà ce que
l'on pouvait retenir de cette grande
journée de manifestation du personnel
hospitalier aujourd'hui à paris
et justement retour en images sur ces
tensions qui ont émaillé la
manifestation des soignants aujourd'hui
regardez
[Applaudissements]
là
je voulais
[Applaudissements]
les lions également des manifestations
se sont tenues dans un climat beaucoup
plus serein nous ont commencé depuis
l'hôpital henri herriot le défilé a
rassemblé environ 6000 personnes selon
la préfecture ils étaient treize mille
selon les syndicats la marche s'est
terminée en face du siège de l'agencé
régionale de santé auvergne un ronald
lors d'un discours les représentants de
la cgt ont demandé une hausse de
salaires de 300 euros et la fin des
suppressions de postes notamment à
l'instar des revendications nationales
voici le témoignage des manifestants on
les a beaucoup oublié
tous ont applaudi pendant c'était un lac
au bide
et puis maintenant qu'il faut aller dans
la rue pour dire pour les soutenir qu'il
faut ouvrir des lits à l'hôpital et
qu'il faut augmenter les salaires n'y a
plus personne est atteinte aux biens de
plus en plus de restrictions
les soignants mais aussi pour les
patients
n'y fait mais pas que pour les soignants
c'est aussi sur les personnes qui seront
finalisés et qui ne peut pas soigner
dans des bonnes conditions par manque de
moyens c'est une catastrophe
c'est une tuerie qui a été préconisée
par notre établissement pendant les
quatre solides
voilà
à la direction bien entendu
ces propos
les rays ont percé
la scène immense honneur niveau là la
citoyenne et qu'on les accompagne et
soutient
et pour barbara coût est infirmière à
l'hôpital lariboisière à paris
coordinatrice du collectif intérieur
chance il était important de se
rassembler aujourd'hui oui on est déçu
on attendait depuis très longtemps de
pouvoir manifester avec tous les
évènements des mois passés on en avait
besoin on avait besoin de se retrouver
de chansons mais de dire qu'on existait
et que on se battait pour tout le monde
pour les patients quand ils consultent
on veut de la dignité à l'hôpital on
veut les moyens qui sont déjà dans les
textes en fait donc c'est ça nous a fait
mal au coeur que ça se déroule de cette
manière mais dans le même temps ça
rejoint toutes les revendications
sociales les espoirs sur le ségur sont
limitées on a l'impression que le jeu il
est déjà fait c'est pas parce qu on
réunit les acteurs autour d'une table
que le débat ait réellement ouvert
aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
si chacun chaque français s'approprient
les problématiques de l'hôpital et se
les fait siennes on pourra aboutir
vrai mouvement de fond pour aboutir à
terme à des modifications et la volonté
de voir la santé comme une priorité pour
l'ensemble de la population française et
autres contestations celle des policiers
ils continuent de manifester leur
mécontentement et que se sont
rassemblées cet après midi devant le
tribunal de créteil les forces de
l'ordre ont symboliquement déposé leurs
menottes en signe de protestation ces
derniers jours plusieurs accusations de
racisme et de violence ont aidé la
police les gardiens nés paix appelle le
gouvernement à prendre des mesures pour
défendre leur profession et côté ce
délégué syndical d'unité-police 94 on
est dans la continuité du mouvement
alors on serra pour sembler devant le tj
à titre symbolique par rapport aux
propos de madame la garde des sceaux qui
a dit que c'était un mouvement d'humeur
qui s'appellera voilà donc on veut lui
prouver aujourd'hui que les policiers ne
lâcherons pas même si c'est pas notre
ministre voilà après dans la continuité
du mouvement
on a on vient par rapport aux
déclarations du président de la
république qui dans son discours nous a
donné que 40 secondes
d'accord un tweet du ministère de
l'intérieur ça ne suffit pas en fait on
est là pour que les autres gouvernements
passent aux actes et arrêtent les
paroles la police va très mal
la police est en attente de beaucoup de
choses de la police l'a fait les gilet
jaune la police elle a fait la grève
générale la police elle a fait la
réforme des retraites
la police elle a fait bataclan est la
fénice elle a fait charlie hebdo
elle a fait récemment l'attentât de
villejuif sur le val de marne voir la
police et va mal qu'on a besoin d'elle
elle est là par contre quand certaines
communautés crient au scandale et nous
traitent tous de raciste là le
gouvernement non contre nous et ça on
peut pas l'accepter et nouvelle
commission d' enquête parlementaire
aujourd'hui devant l'assemblée nationale
jérôme salle ont été entendues le
premier 17 heures le directeur général
de la santé en première ligne au plus
fort de la crise sanitaire alors que
s'est-il passé avec les masques
aurait-on pu sauver des vies dans les
ehpad le confinement il était trop
tardif autant de questions sur la table
pour faire la lumière sur les
défaillances de la gestion de cette
crise déco vide 19 et lors de son
audition jérôme cénomans s'est félicité
de la réponse française à l'épidémie
écoutez je cherche cherche désespérément
un pays qui pourrait se targuer d'avoir
été prêt d'avoir parfaitement géré cette
pandémie compte tenu du caractère
totalement inédit massif meurtrier
brutal de cette pandémie créé on a les
agences régionales de santé qui ont
répondu aux enjeux de surveillance et de
réaction rapide lorsque des premiers cas
sont survenus vraiment la réponse de
terrain a été de très haut niveau et
fabrice di vizio avocat du collectif c
19 ne tire pas le bilan selon lui la
commande des masques a été tardive ils
réclament la publication des bons de
commande
j'ai le premier fait sommation à olivier
ferrand de nous donner la copie des bons
de commande et face à son refus j'ai
saisi la cour de shiloah publique les
bons de commande sont des documents
administratifs communicables c'est la
jurisprudence de la cad à venir à venir
évoquer le secret des affaires et d'une
supercherie intellectuelle qui justifie
les plaintes pénales et je ne comprends
pas que la commission denquête nez
à commencer par ça en exigeant les
boules commandes je pense qu'on va
découvrir qu'en réalité les banques
allemandes ont été extrêmement tardif et
que c'est la raison pour laquelle on n'a
pas réussi à se procurer de masques je
suis quasiment sûre aujourd'hui on
regarde la réticence de l'état est au
faîte du fait qu'il mal à l'aise à ce
point qu'au fond il ya une faille
il ya une défaillance sur ce point je le
dis depuis le premier jour il ya une
défaillance au niveau de l'état
s'agissant des masques et moi je suis
quasiment certain que ces masques ont
été commandés que extrêmement
tardivement et que c'est la raison pour
laquelle on donne autant de mal on a
autant de mal à les communiquer qu'est
ce que ça coûte de les communiquer ça ne
peut que rapporter gros de communiquer
les bons de commande
ça montre à quel point on a été
diligentée quel point c'est pas de notre
faute si on refuse quelque chose qu'à un
tel bénéfice politique c'est que
nécessaire moyens à lui quelque part
pékin referme toutes les écoles et
appelle ses habitants ne pas quitter
dainville la crainte d'une seconde vague
resurgi en chine où tout a commencé plus
d'une centaine de personnes ont été
contaminées depuis la semaine dernière
dans la capitale
le maire a lancé une campagne de
dépistage massif la capacité vient
d'être portée à près de 90 mille tests
par jour se regardent contagion est
partie de l'immense marché de gros de
sin fendi dans le sud de la capitale et
pour contenir l'épidémie la municipalité
a ordonné le confinement de près de 30
zone résidentielle ainsi que des sites
culturels et sportifs
si au sein des csi aucun décès lié au
pot vide 19 n'a encore été détecté
l'om et suit de très près la situation
beijing pékin est une grande ville est
une ville très dynamique et connecté
donc il ya toujours une préoccupation et
je pense que vous pouvez voir ce niveau
de préoccupation dans la réponse des
autorités chinoises
donc nous suivons cela de très près pour
catherine hill épidémiologiste ans que
la france ne testera pas ses citoyens
massivement le virus continue à se
continuera de circuler à oignies a eu de
nouveau quelques cas et ils ont testé 11
millions de personnes en dix jours et
nous on ne fait pas assez de test il
faut trouver les gens qui sont porteurs
du virus et qui en contamine d'autres et
y en a en france tout le temps puisqu'il
ya des nouveaux foyers dont temps il ya
300 nouveaux cas
chaque jour en france et on nous raconte
quelques quelques foyers mais on nous
raconte pas où sont tous les cas et on
nous raconte pas les cas dans les ehpad
on nous raconte pas les cas
asymptomatiques qu'ils restent chez eux
et qu'ils sont pas de diagnostic est
donc je pense que le problème en france
est sous-estimé est sous diagnostiquée
c'est à dire qu'on en sait plus penché
sur le première économique sur le
problème sanitaire et on n'a pas pris la
mesure du problème qui est que la moitié
des contaminations viennent de gens qui
sont pas symptomatique donc ils se
savent pas contaminants donc si on ne
cherche pas les porteurs asymptomatiques
hélas cette façon de les trouver c'est
de faire des tests systématiquement dans
la population qui n'a pas de symptômes
alors l'épidémie continue c'est ce qu'on
voit les tensions en corée alors que la
corée du nord avait fermé et tous les
cas notre communication avec un son
voisin du sud
elle va désormais plus loin elle ce
matin à la détruit un bureau de liaison
d'une ville située près de la frontière
réaction contre les transfuges nord
coréens qui depuis le sud envoie au nord
des tracts de propagande anti kim
jong-un lui met en garde pyongyang
contre de nouveaux actes de provocation
alors que des deux côtés de la frontière
nord et sud coréens se jette la pierre
les nord coréens ne sont pas crédibles
pour le moment peu importe notre
générosité à leur égard ça finit ainsi
c'est pourquoi la corée du sud devrait
également les aborder comme ils le font
actuellement
je pense qu'il n'est pas bien d'être
unilatéralement gentil sans répondre à
leur agressivité
les gens doivent tenir leurs promesses
j'ai vu que le président moon a fait sa
promesse avec la déclaration commune
nord-sud du 15 juin
de telles promesses aurait dû être tenus
par les deux parties plutôt que par une
seule
les autorités sud coréennes sont
désormais contraintes de payer le prix
de leurs crimes et de leur mise en scène
d'un appel au dialogue
nous ne pourrons jamais pardonné à ce
gang ignoble qui a osé tester notre foi
et notre détermination à défendre
d'autres chefs au prix de l'eau vie est
ouvert en septembre 2018 le bureau de
liaison détruits ce matin représentait
le premier instrument physique de
communication ouvert entre les deux pays
depuis cette avancée majeure les
relations entre les deux corées et
n'avait cessé de se détériorer le point
en images
[Musique]
pour
pour dominique traque ancien chef de
mission militaire française à l'onu
l'offensive nord-coréenne permet la
montée en puissance de la soeur de kim
jong hoon pour être un leader en corée
il faut être très martial très va-t-en
guerre et c'est un peu le langage de la
soeur actuellement pour marquer qu'elle
prend sa place dans la hiérarchie auprès
du leader lors de la crise du corps d'un
virus qui a touché un petit peu la corée
aussi on a beaucoup parlé de maladies
qu'avait le leader et en particulier
qu'il avait été opéré
alors tout de suite après on a montré
des images pour montrer que ça n'était
pas vrai mais on se doute qu'il n'est
pas en très très bonne santé et donc il
ya peut-être une manoeuvre qui consiste
à faire monter en premier plan
quelqu'un qui pourrait lui succéder s'il
y avait un problème on le dit depuis
longtemps que c'est quelqu'un de très
influent souvenez-vous les rencontres
elle était présente à côté de son frère
donc ça c'était un des gestes importants
mais là elle apparaît seul donc ça veut
dire qu'elle grimpe encore un cran dans
cette hiérarchie est cette capacité de
lancer des messages
au nom du pays
mais retour à présent sur cette
rencontre dans l'après midi à moscou
entre le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères et son homologue iranien
hormis le dossier nucléaire ça caille
lavrov et jaouad zaïri faut évoquer la
situation en libye et en syrie
le point sur cette réunion avec notre
correspondant à moscou antoine claireaux
oui avec le déconfinement qui se précise
c'est le retour des déplacements
diplomatiques
ainsi sergueï lavrov a accueilli ce
matin à moscou son homologue iranien
javad arrive pour parler de la libye de
la syrie mais avant tout des
conséquences encore aujourd'hui du
retrait américain de l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien signé en 2015 le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères a
dénoncé les pressions qu'exercent les
états unis sur les membres européens de
cet accord sur les pays européens qui
ont signé ce texte vous propose de
l'écouter
après le retrait des états unis de façon
unanime il a terra lé c'était compris
que toutes ces possibilités qui émanait
de l'exécution honnête de cet accord
sont tombés et j'ai donc qui était
stipulé dans la résolution 22 30 heures
des nations unies et les tentatives des
états unis de bloquer l'exécution a
besoin des clauses de cet accord et qui
lui interdisent donc travailler avec
l'iran et qui qui punissent les petits
pays où les entreprises qui travaillent
et qui rompent l'embargo je considère
que c'est l'emploi de moyens illégaux
ceci n'a aucune perspective d'avenir
cela ne permettra pas une reprise des
activités normales et l'ensemble des
obligations tant de l'iran que d autres
signataires
de l'accord tout ça ça fait partie d'un
ensemble cohérent java tarifs a de son
côté remercié son homologue russe pour
avoir envoyé une lettre secrétaire
général des nations unies qui vient
plaider la position de l'iran sur ce
dossier le ministre iranien regrette en
effet que rien n'est fait au niveau des
nations unies pour tenter de sauver cet
accord
ce respect du droit international et les
principes qui demeurait une juillet par
les états unis
ils se sont retirés de l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien ce qui est très
préoccupant pour nous
claironne appellent tous à respecter la
transparence y compris dans le cadre de
la loi et l'iran quoique ceux qui ne
respectent pas les principes de la loi
et essaie de détruire
l'accord je croyais qu'ils ne doivent
pas utiliser les us à cet égard nous
sommes prêts à coopérer avec la russie
pour renforcer la transparence
il a également été question de la syrie
java tarifs revient tout juste d'un
déplacement à ankara et les chefs d'état
de la turquie de la russie et de l'iran
se sont mis d'accord sur la tenue d'un
nouveau sommet dans le cadre du
processus d'astana afin de tenter de
trouver une issue politique au conflit
en syrie un sommet qui devrait se tenir
avant le mois d'août est très
probablement en vidéoconférence
donald compte réduire le nombre de
militaires américains stationnés en
allemagne leurs effectifs se réduisent
et art deux conséquences cela restera un
engagement américain au niveau européen
dans le cadre de l'otan pour le
président américain
berlin ne contribue pas assez au budget
de l'alliance transatlantique
nous avons 52 mille soldats en allemagne
ça fait énormément de soldats c'est un
coup énorme pour les états unis et
l'allemagne comme vous le savez est très
en retard dans ses paiements à l'otan
des arriérés ça fait des années qu'ils
ont des arriérés
ils doivent des milliards de dollars à
l'otan et il faut qu'il paie ce nous
protégeons l'allemagne ils ont des
arriérés c'est ridicule
coup dur pour les relations entre les
deux pays est un camouflet pour berlin
je vous propose d'écouter d'injection un
ministre allemand des affaires
étrangères et ico masse et celle de jens
stoltenberg secrétaire général de l'otan
nous pensons que la présence américaine
en allemagne est importante pour la
sécurité non seulement de l'allemagne
mais aussi pour la sécurité des états
unis et particulièrement pour la
sécurité de l'europe les etats-unis ont
également indiqué clairement que la
manière et le moment exact de la mise en
oeuvre de cette décision et ne sont pas
encore décidés je pense donc qu'il est
important que nous ayons maintenant un
dialogue au sein de l'otan sur cette
question s'agit d'un accord bilatéral
entre les états unis et l'allemagne
mais il est bien sûr important pour
l'ensemble de l'alliance
à tafas à la commission européenne
bruxelles annonce aujourd'hui avoir
ouvert plusieurs enquêtes contre la
marque à la pomme
la commission européenne soupçonne le
géant américain de pratiques anti
concurrentielles notamment sur le marché
de la musique en ligne du livre audio ou
des services de paiement électronique de
son côté la firme de copertino se défend
de tout abus de position dominante
il est décevant que la commission
européenne avance des plainte infondée
de la part d'une poignée d'entreprises
qui veulent simplement profiter de la
situation sans payer ni jouer selon les
mêmes règles que le reste du monde nous
ne pensons pas que ce soit juste
nous voulons maintenir des conditions de
concurrence équitables ou toute personne
déterminée ayant une idée prometteuse
peut prospérer très pour olivier iteanu
avocat spécialiste du droit numérique
apple comme les autres gars femme est en
position de monopole et les enquêtes de
bruxelles arrive même un peu tard la
réalité c'est quoi c'est que c'est sega
femmes puisque apple fait partie des
gars femmes google apple facebook et
amazon et on peut ajouter microsoft en
fait sont des oligopoles sont à nos
digues open se sont chacun des monopoles
quand on entend le communiqué de presse
de la société apple c'est une blague
non seulement ils sont en en art en
position dominante alors la bu ça c'est
une enquête qui le dira mais ils sont en
position d ondes ils sont en position
monopolistique et l'europe étant une des
seule région au monde où ces entreprises
disposent d'un tel monopole ces enquêtes
ne sont pas une surprise à vienne très
tard elles viennent très très tard toute
la vague du numérique nouvelles
générations arrivées avec google qui a
été créée en 1998 aux états unis
méritent arrivée en europe en 2003
facebook en 2005 twitter en 2007
en réalité très peu de ces sociétés ont
été poursuivis condamné pour des
problèmes de concurrence
mais maintenant les choses s'enchaînent
et situation toujours aussi inquiétantes
en amérique latine et aux caraïbes la
barre des 80 mille décès liés aux
coronavirus était franchie dans la
région au chili
l'état des sections constitutionnel pour
catastrophe a été prolongée de trois
mois pour maintenir le couvre-feu
nocturne et le confinement notamment le
panama qui conclut de 21 mille cas pour
un peu moins de 500 morts a lancé une
grande campagne de dépistage
la différence aujourd'hui et que nous
utilisons les nouveaux kits qui ont été
livrés à toutes les régions pour faire
des tests rapides qui nous donneront des
résultats en 30 minutes environ
maison par maison l'intention est de
continuer à tester de plus en plus par
exemple ces trois derniers jours plus de
600 nouveaux cas ont été recensés et
c'est pour cela que nous sommes en train
d'étendre les tests et c'est la fin de
ce journal merci d'avoir suivi prochain
rendez-vous avec l'actualité 7 heures du
matin heure française excellente fin de
soirée tout sur rt france
[Musique]
oui
ça fait maintenant plusieurs je dirais
décennies presque que la france ou
financent sa recherche et son
enseignement supérieur à quoi est-ce que
vous attribuez ce manque de moyens c'est
un un problème politique au sens où ça
serait à gauche ben le projet politique
la recherche la place qu'elles devraient
avoir parce que la recherche est un
élément central dans la prise en compte
et très très grand défi auquel